foreign
[Music]
go
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
check it out
[Music]
three two one
check it out
[Music]
foreign
hi
[Music]
screw you
see you
[Music]
bye
welcome ladies and gentlemen to the
puzzle world championship this is a much
awaited event where everyone comes
together to solve a whole lot of Chess
puzzles and we determine who the best
puzzle solver in the world is I'm your
host GM Daniel nerdinski and alongside
me today is w-i-m anamaya Kazarian
anamaya welcome to the show good
afternoon to you
thank you Dania welcome everyone I'm
beyond excited for this event Dania we
will have so many puzzles today and we
will have the top players in puzzle Raj
participating for tomorrow's final Ray
Robson Jeffrey Zhang Andrew Tang Anna
krambling all of the streamers are live
all of the great people are solving so
we will be tuning into their streams to
check out their progress but first we
need to talk a little bit about the
format because the format changes from
day to day this is day one and on day
one the format is pretty simple players
have 30 minutes to guess the best
three-minute puzzle Rush score so the
single best score counts they've got 30
minutes to do as many attempts as they
can fit in uh the Run starts before the
time count is up so if they start a run
with two seconds left on the clock that
potentially counts the top 20 finishers
in each 30-minute batch advance to round
two then of those the top two Advanced
to the puzzle battle round and then the
bottom 15 qualify into the next round so
two players keep qualifying uh in every
round and Amaya until there are no
players left
right Daya so the top two players will
advance to tomorrow's knockout bracket
but the top 20 will advance to the
second round so first we'll have uh the
top 20 that qualifies in the first round
moving on to the second round and every
single time the players are playing 30
minutes of three model minute puzzle
rushes so a lot of puzzles that will be
played today and I'm beyond excited to
see who will advance to tomorrow's
knockout bracket and without question
Ray Robson is the Czar the king of
Puzzle Battle will he be unseated will a
surprise Contender emerge on the scene
somebody who's been practicing puzzle
rush and grinding for hours in secret so
far anemiah Rey hasn't just dominated he
is dominated by a country mile it hasn't
even been close but there are definitely
players still vying for second and third
place and Ray is human I know the jury
is still out on that but will we see any
surprises this this year what do you
think
we'll have to see I think by far Ray
Robson is the favorite we know that
Jimmy is also a very strong at puzzle
rushes
um I've played against these players a
couple of puzzle battles and I know
there's strength they're insanely good I
was really happy to see a lot of new
contenders this year I saw some
submissions on Twitter where there was
someone that submitted
um that had 60 a score of 60 in five
minutes which is insane to me so I'm
really looking forward to see if there
will be surprises but first let's have a
look what is at stake there are in total
000 in prizes the top 20 finishers
advance to round two and earn at least
two hundred dollars Diane and an
additional 200 for each round that they
survive subsequently and the minimum
price in The Knockout phase is a cool
1000 G's so plenty of money at stake but
of course for someone like Ray Robson
what's really at stake is his reputation
as the king of Puzzle Battle the money
is a nice bonus but for the top guys
they really want to assert themselves as
the best puzzle solver in the world
which of course is the entire point of
this event so nmi we've got lots of
great prizes we've got every Grand
Master you can think of competing for
those top prizes we really couldn't ask
for a more entertaining way to spend the
next couple of days in the next couple
of hours
absolutely Daya I am beyond excited for
this event will we see Ray Robson
succeed again or will be will there be
some surprises uh we see that Ray Robson
is already live He's practicing as we're
about to start uh with the first round
the first 30 minute segment here we see
him he just scored 51 Daya that's beyond
insane and for him he's like okay I got
51 time for the next run it'll be so
interesting to see uh this run because
only the top score counts so players can
actually take a lot of risks right it's
not about every single run counting you
can really Gamble and try to solve even
faster than you normally would so in in
Rey's case I'm expecting a high score of
maybe 55 maybe he'll even get to 60. I
mean nothing surprises me when it comes
to Ray Robinson anymore let's see what
he's saying
do you see that number down at the 6038
number I typically see this when I make
a mistake on the first puzzle and I'm
rage creating because I'm like okay this
one is not going well I see I recognize
this number being around 2 000 for me
when that happens this guy has 51 and
it's numbered 6038 how many puzzle
brushes has Ray Robson sold
so what that means is that he's had 6
000 runs over 50 is that what that means
so this is his six thousandth best
performance and he got 51 on a three
minute run
is what you're saying yeah that's
exactly what I'm saying and um I I have
not been able to hit 50 just yet in
three minutes so this is insanity and
here we go we are off you can see the
ticker starting to move on the upper
left side of your screen that means each
subsequent run is going to count
officially and there he goes be still my
Beating Heart now Rey isn't necessarily
the fastest solver anime in the first
minute he's very methodical though he
almost never makes mistakes in the first
20 30 puzzles like ever
yeah I mean 16 uh solved in around 30
seconds is I mean it's a really good
score of course uh but you can be much
faster but he's very principled he has
this pace throughout the entire
three-minute run which is key this is
how you get a higher score
and if you look at 45 seconds of his run
you could say okay he's got 25 26 you
know you might have seen players get 30
in a minute so you're like what's the
what's the whole fuss about now you
pointed out the most important thing
which is that this is the face he keeps
even when he gets to the 40s and
sometimes even the 50s and I think
you're about to see that here he goes
wow the piece I mean it's just steady
okay those you just and the way he
eliminates tempting options nmi that
would probably take me like 10-15
seconds to refute he somehow just knows
he's like nope this isn't correct his
intuition and Puzzle Battle is insane
the key in Puzzle Battle is that you
there's one solution so you you see
there's a check okay you have to solve
this check and you have to make sure
that if they limit all the options in
the really short time frame and that is
important in Puzzles that's how you
improve your score make sure that you
eliminate those options quickly and go
for forcing moves because that's how you
solve the puzzles yeah and that's how
you know that some options are incorrect
if they're insufficiently forcing or
they allow too many options in return
unless we're talking high 50s it's
probably not the solution but making
those judgments in like a millisecond is
crazy and there he goes he's got 47
that's Checkmate on F2 let's see how
quickly he can get to 50. Knight F3
Knight takes C1 takes D3 takes G7
flawlessly executed and there's a little
Fork to get to 49 I think yep wow Queen
takes G5 wow I think it's Queen A4
Bishop B5 50. 50 with 30 seconds left
and look at how quickly he continues to
solve
how does he do this oh this one's
impossible I think this might be Queen
H2
no then Queen F3 check but you're down a
lot of material with the white pieces
then yeah that was a tough one and that
was a good call by Ray to eliminate that
one because he's got two strikes Bishop
D7 and Rook C5 made in two
wow
oh take the queen
53.8 king is running away oh
no yesterday yeah he does it
oh Bishop F6 oh can you get in one
second
53 on his first run we just started yeah
there's 27 minutes left
if that were my highest score
yeah um the thing is his pace is so
insane he makes it look so easy like
he's solving the first 10 puzzles like
most of us will do at the fast pace but
he does this for the final 10 puzzles as
well and when he's in his 40s so I I
just cannot process this how does he do
this how can he solve this so quickly
yeah that's always been the most
surprising element of Rey's master of
course the consistency is amazing how
rarely he has like bad runs where he
gets one wrong you know in the first uh
minute or so but also just how quickly
he solves the puzzles in the 40s and 50s
it's I I can probably watch this for
many many hours and still you know fail
to understand how this is possible
yeah absolutely crazy he's gonna get
he's like he's speeding up oh Queen E3
was made in one
some puzzles are super sneaky there it
feels like it has you know
um some there's some move that really
feels good but there is a minor detail
that is missing or there is simply a
Checkmate in one or two which is
significantly better than winning for
example peace
yeah and another tilting component we
were talking before the show those
puzzles that you assume you've already
solved them because you like take a
queen and then they just keep going and
they force you to find a defensive move
and finding defensive moves in Puzzle
Battle might actually be the hardest
thing uh the hardest type of move that
they force you to find
absolutely and yeah I mean he already
has a very good score and I would be
really surprised if he doesn't make it
to the top 20 with that enormous score
yeah he could just chill probably for
the rest of
you can just you know grow up some tea
and watch the others suffer for 25
minutes of course he's not gonna do that
he's gonna go for 60. and uh speaking of
I was gonna say speaking of suffering it
looks like a Benjamin
Bachman is hot on Rey's tail he is
another very experienced and very
stalwart puzzle solver but King Ray
King Ray is Unstoppable
yeah and here we also see everyone the
scoreboard of the players so far as we
know that the top 20 advances to round
two so it's important to get into top 20
and it also earns you 200 at least so
this top 20 is really important and it's
also like if you don't make it to the
top 20 it's like you've played 30
minutes of Paul George and that's it
it's uh it's so unfortunate but Ah
that's the format yeah it's a lot of
time but you also can't you know you
can't fall asleep because the time
really does creep up on you there's 53
from rake and he gets a 54. I think 53
is the current top scorer Krista for you
let's not forget about him he's another
beast and there he goes 54 by Ray wait
was it just run like not really perfect
and he's already at 55. he got he made
two mistakes in like the first 30
puzzles and he still gets to 55. there's
also I believe wow
check is a life leaderboard and he's
still not satisfied he's like no I got
that one wrong and he got 56. I guess in
the first one
yeah absolutely insane and uh yeah and
there's a lot of players catching up to
him but Barely There are 54-53 there's a
few people in the 50s but who will make
it to the top 20 they're still 23
minutes left so the players have a lot
of time and did you know Diana died as
long as you start your run before the
timer runs out it still counts so you
can like end your run uh when you are
not satisfied with it and just make sure
that it starts before the time runs out
that's actually one of the most
important skills to know when you don't
have much of a chance now if you're
right you can get two wrong in the first
10 puzzles and you'll still have a
chance to get 55 but for the other
players knowing when to quit as you said
and giving yourself another chance is a
really important skill we have a super
cool four board view uh of four
streamers competing simultaneously
that's Benjamin Bach on the top left we
know who that is on the top right needs
no introduction Anna crawling on the
bottom left uh and on the bottom right
we have none other than Andrew Tang who
might be the fastest solver annamaya in
the first minute which is not a surprise
given his bullet skills indeed we all
know how fast Andrew Tang is the hyper
bullet Master uh we should say and uh
let's uh let's have a look how he's
doing he's currently 43 and he has one
minute and 20 seconds left but this is
the deceptive thing I've had these runs
before where you think I must I'm I'm
definitely gonna get 55. he's already
gotten too wrong though and we take it
for granted that these puzzles are easy
when you watch Rey solve them right but
then you see somebody else solve them
and you realize they're actually pretty
much impossible but let's watch his
first minute this is gonna be insane
I need to know which Mouse he's using
I actually he's using an old mouse uh I
actually asked him a couple years ago
uh he's using azio which is a model I
think that's not produced anymore and
it's a Wired Mouse so he's very old
school
wow
and he quit after he got one wrong
that's the tricky part
what did he say he says I think he was
answering a question from someone in
chat who asked if he could make 60 and
he said no but we all know how modest he
is I think the answer is probably yes
Rook G7 given his speed if he keeps this
up he could
he just needs to be a little bit more
careful on the ones in the 40s castanoke
with a great run there 45 by chess Queen
oh Queen takes Rook H3
so far so good let's see if he can get
30 in under a minute
that'll be crazy I remember the days
that I used to consider 20 in one minute
like golden
it's pretty good
what's this one what's going on I don't
understand which way the pawns are going
you know those puzzles yes I hate them
you have to figure out like you spent
five seconds just trying to figure out
which side you're on who's like whose
turn it is and where the pawns are
moving yeah where you live who the
president is like what month is it
these puzzles so you can see that Andrew
generally tends to end the run when he
gets one wrong let's say under puzzle
number 40 which is sensible
but eventually he'll need to complete an
actual run like eventually he'll need to
try his best in in three minutes
I mean we saw Ray Robson have a mistake
in the early 2030s and he kept going and
still had a very high score so uh you
could argue that maybe he should
continue and keep up the pace and just
ignore the fact that he made a mistake
because you still have two strikes yeah
Ray I mean the way that he approaches
Those runs might be the most impressive
aspect of his Mastery to me he just does
not tilt he'll get one wrong or he'll
Mouse slip occasionally
and he just continues with the same
exact Pace as if nothing's the matter
oh wow nicely done there by Andrew that
was a tough one takes E7 and Rook F6
35 in one minute by the way unbelievable
that's maybe the most I've ever seen as
he picks up the rook and gets himself to
40 C5 no he needs to keep going
yeah this is a good run he's got a
chance here to get at least 50.
looking good
G3 yes take the Rook Bishop F5 and then
back to D3 I think yeah
oh tricky though queen f595 queen F5
Knight G5 Andrew you got it okay he does
it
oh what is this one queen of two I think
I think it is Queen G4 Queen G4 yeah you
need to take on E6 oh Knight G6
impossible yeah you're exactly right
sacking first was wrong and he's losing
some steam here
good stuff there might be through with a
fork take the bishop no okay we have to
take the Rook first
yeah
is those small differences that hurt so
much like you see the tactic you know
what's going on but this small
difference ah and you can't help
yourself you can't hold yourself back
sometimes you're just so you know you're
already used to moving so quickly that
just knowing when to stop for those
additional two seconds
is what we take for granted from someone
like Ray
oh yep
nicely done there let's see if we can
imagine it's 35.
wow light Focus
take it
queen queen
thinks she's seven thank you yeah yeah
it's a block with a queen there from C3
those retreating moves oh God he needs
to calm himself down here a little bit
[Laughter]
it's always funny when you get the first
one wrong that's the ultimate sign of
tilt
yeah
very relatable
extremely
surely he is in the top 20 already right
I don't I don't see him in a scoreboard
just yet but he must be in the top 20.
ah I think it's close because number 20
right now is 45. I don't know if he got
four wow
jibaba currently in in 20th foreign
a lot of big names on the scoreboard
rhetoric savane the brother of
rasmusvani now also Grandmaster getting
54.
wait they're both so good wow yeah
they're unbelievable love to see that
I heard a lot yeah but Frederick was in
the shadows he was an FM and he went
from FM to GM I think without even being
an I am
wow
so thank you taken King G7
taking King G7 I think it's these
puzzles that typically like if you have
you had over the board you would
calculate it because it
s time but in puzzles
you know you have no other choice
there's no better way to deal with the
position than to just to take and run
with the pawn and hope that is correct
yeah if you see an option like that it's
usually it's usually the one because
it's as you
as forcing Queen oh nice
take it in the fork this is a good one
he's got zero strikes now watch me say
that and oh no
he did it correctly
it's excellent take it
okay 44 take it take it taking a bishop
B4 and Rook D2 it's Queen 62. I should
have seen that one fast
nice this looks good
oh do you take on e4 and F2 okay like
that three
three four uh where's the mate oh nice
King f8 no
wait what which perspective are we
looking from oh why is going that way
yeah
what's going on the pawn all the black
of white and black are both promoting
Queen D1 Queen D1 Fork the bishop no no
that's Queen D1
he's just not seeing it and sometimes
you just have those blind spots
I was still trying to figure out where
coin do you wanna was uh yeah
oh Knight G1 there was The Mating move
no take the other Rook
okay not bad 50 is not bad because the
top 20 is currently around 48.
No it should be enough actually I think
but still 14 minutes left five rounds 14
minutes left yeah it's crazy we've only
been probably been watching for 15
minutes plenty of time for more runs
let's see if we can switch to somebody
else perhaps
um I don't know if we have access to
maybe Benjamin box stream
but we're sticking with Andrew for now
here he goes again
[Music]
and there we are Benjamin Buck is on our
camera
okay let's have a look
as high as was I I'm pretty sure I saw
him on the score but I just uh don't
recall his top score
um but let's see let's see how he's
doing how fast he is yeah let's and I'm
always curious how how much uh people
score in the first minute so far pretty
darn fast
okay and Benjamin obviously one of the
best survival puzzle rushers in the
world he's gotten
you know insane scores in puzzle Rush
survival he's also one of the most
patient remember those streams he'd go
hours yeah hours on a single puzzle
yeah I remember very well I'm pretty
sure he's holding the world record at
least uh on stream uh which is very very
impressive
Rook D3 is mate no Benjamin Rook D3 you
got it oh that's a really crucial
yeah you really can't make any unless
you're right you cannot afford to make
mistakes in the first 35 puzzles or so
okay he's gotten 25 in a minute
he's gotten some puzzles this bad yeah
that hurts a lot sometimes you have so
many Checkmate in one puzzles and
sometimes you just have really an
unlucky run
I suppose it's part of the fun with this
Rook f88 I guess
you're supposed to make just a quiet
move on the 28th puzzle
yes Anastasia's mate
nice yeah and swing wait that was that
was very tricky I would expect it around
50. all of these are and suddenly I made
in one
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay block with the bishop no oh The
Rook in the corner
yeah that stuff he does have a score of
49 so he is currently still in top 20
but look how stacked it is it's getting
really tight over there on the
scoreboard yeah number 20 is 48 so if
you want to guarantee qualification you
really should try to make it to 51 or
52.
11 30 to go
and Benjamin's gonna reach 40 but can he
get to 50 not this time yep very nice G6
Queen G7
I think I had this puzzle uh on Monday
during chess play quick remember
yeah there's some patterns that you just
recognize
yeah because you've solved so many of
them that you just like know exactly
what type of puzzle that is it's G7
who went and checked my donations and
another Anastasia's mate type
Construction
those ones are so satisfying because you
it's always some Knight G3 move and then
there's some check me on the H file and
sometimes it's a retreating move of the
queen like Queen C5 to A3 and
okay this is a good one for Benjamin can
he get to 50. Knight F7 Queen G8
oh a few seconds left I don't see it can
he do this
no oh he does oh 49 49 oh but it's the
same score as you already had
again 49. shoot
um
there you go a little bit too slow at
the start I think if he had gotten 28 or
29 in the first minute he would have
gotten to 50.
yeah and it said that it was his sixth
all-time best so he knows he can do
better
it's kind of chilling he's got 10
minutes
and he's analyzing the one he got wrong
I think you should get going there he
goes again
I think the players also are not 100
aware of the scoreboard
um which is which makes it really Hearts
to figure out how you're doing and
um yeah what the rest is doing like
which place are you are is your score
sufficient because personally I would
think that 49 is more than enough to
qualify for the top 20.
yeah but I I don't I wonder if knowing
the scores will make you more motivated
or more nervous I think it depends on
the type of solver you are and the type
of person you are
so to give you an example of something
similar when I'm playing matches
I actually have stopped looking at the
match timer I remember I played a match
with Andrew Tang
um and I was up by five going to the
bullet section and everything was going
great then I look at the match timer and
I see there's 15 minutes left and I
start getting so nervous I'm like if I
win one more game I can probably stall
it out and I I end up losing four in a
row so just like knowing additional
information can sometimes actually make
you more nervous but in this case
probably it's helpful to know how
panicked you should be and how many how
many risks you should take
yeah I mean that that additional
information can just make you so nervous
and
um unnecessarily if you just keep going
whatever you're doing and just don't
focus on anyone else I think it's indeed
much better
agreed we also have Grandmaster Min lay
also known as wonderful time
a chess.com
let's switch to his stream I'm I'm
pretty blind now
is it most talkative of everyone we've
seen so far
he's absolutely okay he's adorable I
mean is just such takes C4 and Bishop D6
oh tricky oh in check I do that all the
time me too I'm like oh I I thank God I
was in check because otherwise it would
have been a mistake anyway
50. 50 okay
that should be enough 50 is actually
already together in place there's a huge
tie in top 20 they are on getting like
49 you know
I think the 50 actually safer you can
say that but still no right now yep
it's good for the one guys whoops
I cannot oh no let's go that red
anything in red is already a bad sign
okay let's see how quick he is in the
first minute
okay we'll try another one and we're
trying to completely Focus I can follow
the screen off
it happens all the time yeah
is those Rook uh moves on the other side
of the to the other side of the board
that are the hardest honestly yeah
because your handles are basically
shaking to begin with so yeah
um
rugby one
oh nice
and that was a tricky one because Queen
takes E6 was very tempting yes
um before and here and here is I would
have just taken on B7 right away it was
check it was checked that's fine
um okay I'm gonna slower now guys I can
feel that
I think you should take G7 no okay good
thing I'm not doing it right take it and
look after work so it's fine we'll see
it and then here
okay and it's very accurate yeah he's
consistent yeah yeah yeah you're admit
as well too
and it mirrors his chest style very
disciplined she three obviously the
answer is not here could be 596 and then
I think this one I think I don't see
anything else Queen F3
Queen H3
okay and this is I love how he thinks
out loud yeah this is entertaining to
watch he talks a lot more than most
other solvers but it's good for us um
he does our job
exactly I think you have to take the
bishop still here okay here yeah
um G4
um
queen of three getting tricky then when
G4 again
um can you strapped
um nice I think win H3 maybe I think a
is free
yeah the pawns are gonna one of them are
gonna promise
sorry
um Knight B5 it's Knight B5
oh my Lord
um that's a tough one that's the most
sophisticated I've seen today and it was
a maiden two but one of the toughest
maidens okay we'll see yeah but it's
good time five maybe is there okay to
eat
oh great I'm dropping the queen oh but
what's next oh
no you got that one that was impressive
again
wow
oh again again and there's only four
minutes left on the clock okay but this
should should be sufficient I think 50
is gonna be the dividing score
and if multiple people get the same
score let's say number 20 is 50 and
number 21 is 50. I guess I'm not sure
what the tie breaks are Anna Maya uh
like a couple of the tie Break
um uh let me see from
um I knew what the tie break was uh I'll
uh quickly look it up for you because
um there is definitely going to be a tie
Break
um there's no question about it
especially in the first round
um
hmm
um I I don't really I don't yeah we'll
find that out for you
also Andrew Tang apparently got 54. so
he should be in
mm-hmm
here goes Min again let's see if he can
get 51 to close off the first 30 minute
segment
he seems to be doing it faster this time
yeah he's taking some risks he knows he
already has a 50 in his pocket so
no need to know
Oh My Lens
[Music]
[Laughter]
GH
take the no Rook d8 probably no Knight
F3 Knight H2 good stuff no no I fall for
that damn it that's the only thing he
can do though damn engine
Queen F6
check check check and mate
yeah two strikes is rough
Queen G3 oh my
God damn girl King G3 and F2
this is a tough batch but he's got 41 in
a minute if he didn't have two strikes I
think this would have been a good one
he's he's faster than the previous uh
runs for sure for sure
yeah what the heck oh G6 you're not
supposed to take either Pawn just that
F6 F6 I guess
oh wow F7 crazy
I guess you check C2
let's see anything else
she's just taking the route but what's
next this is what I'm talking about I
guess it's Knight C2 back and it
continues nothing before oh wow yeah
Queen B4 was crucial
what's this
I'm my head is spinning Queen H5 G6
all right
men is just puzzles hmm
Fisher G5 oh wow out of nowhere
I guess it's King G5 I don't say I think
again damn it
48 not bad I think you can do here
and one minute 20 seconds enough for one
more run I don't know if I can offender
one but let's let's try whatever right I
don't know what I mean
I know I know I know I know
I mean I don't think if this is gonna be
counted but it will just keep doing
things
I have a big surprise for this I can
like you know do things for raise in
first place
oh really I know you would never you
would have never thought oh my Lord
crazy and you know what's crazier we
will still see him in round two I know
he made it somehow
great drops and qualifies to the next
round of a puzzle battle championships
what's going is the world still spitting
on its axis
[Laughter]
Queen G5
okay this is going to be the final run
for all players this is great with 56.
and the dividing score
I guess is 50. what's number 20 let's
see
yeah no 49 still gets you in Jeffrey
Sean he's trying to squeak through
um oh it's getting really close over
there
yeah 49 might not make it
and that's it the timer is up whatever
run the players are on this is going to
be the last one that counts
oh no he doesn't have time
I feel like I just you should make a
note I think he got 50. okay that is
enough yeah should be yes
you know Dania I think I just remember
the tie Break
um I think it is your best run is being
counted and they look how big your
streak was the biggest streak will be
placed higher like number of puzzles
gotten correct in a row yeah in that
same run in that run yes
so if you had 50 a streak of 50 uh
you're doing a great job
yeah and somebody like Ray is gonna have
amazing tie breaks because of how
consistent he is yeah yeah
okay luckily got that knife four wait
but he is at 47 he still has 50 seconds
oh another one 48. Rook G1 okay
oh what huge
left
okay I missed oh no
H5 was the move
that's it okay so Min is gonna make it
nonetheless or is he I think where is he
now it's about who has a better tie
breaks on 50 because everyone that is on
49 is out of the top 20. you're right 49
does not make it and we will sort the
tie breaks out during the break but
ladies and gentlemen the minimum score
that qualifies you is 50. not even
everybody who got 50 is going to make it
a couple unlucky tiebreakers are going
to get eliminated so first stage of the
puzzle battle World Championship is
complete 20 lucky players are going to
make it through they include Ray Robson
Krista for you and The Usual Suspects we
will have the full list for you on the
other side of the break here at The
Puzzle Battle World Championship we'll
be right back
Tata steel is famous for its tournament
lineup featuring a creative mix of
superstars and super talents that always
guarantees Fighting Chess what a
devastating moment chess.com will be
bringing you the action the drama and
the emotions Live January 13th through
January 29th don't miss history in the
making
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
go
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the puzzles World
Championship we are one around in 20
players have qualified to the next day
today include Grandmaster Ray Robson we
will be looking into as round two kicks
off we remind you that two of the top
finishers make their way directly into
the puzzle battle knockout while the
bottom three scores are eliminated in
the 15 in between have to earn it once
again in the following round GM daily
ski women's International Master anime
Kazarian bringing you the commentary
today so nmi I don't think I did the
best job of explaining the format but
all you really have to know is that the
top two finishers qualify and then the
bottom three are eliminated
you did great Dania welcome back
everyone we are now moving on to round
to another series of 30 minutes of three
minute puzzle rushes and the streamers
the players are going to fight again for
the top places because as Danya said the
top two advances to tomorrow's final
knockout bracket and the bottom three
gets eliminated the rest continues to
the next round and we have in total five
rounds uh of those 30 minute segments so
a lot of excitement and I'm really
excited to see who will now advance to
tomorrow's knockout bracket yeah me too
things are getting more heated in round
one we saw that a score of 50
essentially got you through this time 50
as far is gonna be a far from a
guarantee now it doesn't necessarily
mean that the players who got 56 are
going to repeat their performance right
you're never that consistent unless your
name is Ray Robson so we will start by
looking at razor on he'll probably get
55 in the very first run of the 30
minutes but the players do got about 50
and squeaked their way through they're
gonna have to put through a bit of a
stronger performance this time animaya
if they want to stay in the tournament
absolutely you have to be so precise and
so consistent because 50 in three
minutes is not a joke it's beyond insane
and
um I I wish I could hit 50 in three
minutes that's insane I was really happy
to it in five minutes but three minutes
it goes by so fast and the puzzles get
more and more tough
yeah they do they do and we saw a lot of
very difficult batches uh this time
around it seems like Rey is totally
immune to them
um but the other players obviously they
struggled we saw a lot of players
getting to 30 35 really quickly and then
really struggling uh in let's say
puzzles 35 to 45 that's where you want
to go flawlessly in order to give
yourself a chance to get 50 but we'll
see the puzzles should kick off any
second we will start Where it All Began
on this stream of Grand Master Roy
Robson
yeah I'm really looking forward to see
him go at it again he has a tab now of
4554 in three minutes will he repeat it
now again uh as we're about to start the
next segment of 30 minutes or three
minute puzzle rushes
oh Ray Robson 54
uh in between the puzzles this is what
he gets during the break when there's
nothing on the line he just kind of
casually does another one and gets 54.
uh we can see the round one standings
there on the left side of your screen a
lot of people getting 52 I'm pretty
impressed they include Bortnick but look
at the players who got 54. Andrew Tang
of course jimis and Jimmy's is a really
interesting player because he's not all
that strong in Blitz but an incredible
puzzle solver
yeah I've seen him play many many times
and he is
um you know just like Ray Robson just
extremely good at puzzles and he is
capable uh of defeating Ray Robson but
is he as consistent as Ray Robson that's
the question
like we will see and re-adjusting his
shirt collar there as he prepares to
start these 30 minutes the ticker should
begin any second now let's get the show
on the road
and uh as we did previously we will go
from stream to stream and look as these
players try their best to make their way
into the next round
you know I'm seeing this username Liam
Putnam 2008. does this mean that this
person is 15 years old hitting a score
of 51 in three minutes
unbelievable yeah I'm just mesmerized by
these scores now my top score was 53 and
that's through about a year of solving
so to get 53 in 30 minutes I honestly
have no words
absolutely crazy and once again the
score 54 of Ray Robson is his number
4316. so there are basically 2 000
almost 2 000 runs where he scored
between 50 and 54. so that goes to show
how many times he has hit this score and
it it almost feels like for him probably
that it's like any other day in the
office yeah it really does
and uh okay we have Liam Putnam we have
a couple of players who we can recognize
for Marina Kings and from title Tuesday
great to see them all come together
Jeffrey Zhang is also uh seems like he
also made it to the top 20. we see
videos also in standings here but did he
make it
um we'll have to see that but it would
be really awesome to see him also making
it to the top 20.
yeah for sure
um but what we see is that rating
doesn't necessarily always translate to
success in puzzle rush I mean we've seen
a lot of the players from older
Generations like Alexander grishek I
think uh Mahmoud Yara was trying his
luck at Puzzle Battle they don't always
get you know high 50s so I think that
the older players are used to taking
their time they're not necessarily used
to solving for Pure speed so it's always
interesting to see which players manage
to adjust to the constraints of Puzzle
Battle itself
right and maybe let's ask the chat what
is your highest puzzle Rush uh score in
three minutes we'd love to see some of
your scores in the chat we know we're
looking at really high numbers here but
we'll also appreciate some other numbers
from you what is your highest uh we all
know that since it is puzzle week
everyone is now able to have access to
puzzle features on the website uh for
free today uh puzzle rush and Puzzle
Battle are access uh accessible for
everyone for free so let us know what is
your highest score
I see some zeros but I also see some
pretty impressive scores 39 photo chess
in the chat hello Maria 40. is photo
chest a site I think that's the high
score right now in the chat minus one
yeah that's a pretty interesting score
s totally believable
yeah I think um maybe Ray Robson got
close to it no I actually um are you up
since highest is 69. so a pretty nice
guy
yes 69 I can just repeat that score and
it just does not add up well okay not in
not for that reason but it just does not
add up that's crazy
my average is about 57 wow
um that's beyond impressive yeah it is
indeed uh more than a one Grand Master
all right um the players are waiting we
are waiting we are about to start with
the second round
um do you think you know I I have a
feeling very often we'll just take it
um the first place and simply continue
uh to tomorrow's final bracket just like
that what do you think is the biggest
Contender for second place I I would say
it's between jimus Christopher you
and I honestly I mean Andrew Tang is an
incredibly fast puzzle so I just given
his speed in the first minute
statistically he's likely to have a run
where he gets mid 50s so I'm actually
really I think if anybody can unseat Ray
Robson Andrew Tang has a shot given out
insanely fast he is in the first like 30
35 puzzles we saw him get 35 in a minute
which is absolutely unbelievable
I'm sorry that I could not help but
laugh at the fact that Andrew Tang was
simply refreshing the page of the timer
to see when it's starting yeah he's he's
impatient he's we're all rearing to go
uh it should start any second now
is just hard refreshing
this is great
um yeah yeah we're all waiting uh and
we're getting bored that we are about to
start guys so uh don't go anywhere
you're about to see some crazy action
from the players because the speed is
amazing it's barely possible to keep up
with
um their puzzles like you see the puzzle
and boom it's gone like you don't even
have the moment to see whose turn it is
yeah a lot of players and a lot of
people watching they don't understand
how it's even physically possible to
solve that fast and that's just how
pattern recognition works right that
that is the magic of pattern recognition
your brain registers certain patterns in
the position whether it's a back rank
weakness whether it's Anastasia's mate
before your eyes even catch up to the
actual position so uh that's just kind
of how that works and there you see it
like your brain already tells you what
aspects of the position are important so
you don't even need to know where all
the pieces are where the rest of the
pieces are and there he goes Andrew
tanks finally we are underway
and here we go
this is his first run and look at that
speed we're barely able to keep up with
the board
um but he has a score with 18 now uh
barely spend 25 seconds on that so let's
see if it can keep up that pace and have
a good score here
so far so good by Andrew Clean Run thus
far 25 he's got 25 seconds
in the first minute and he wins the
queen winning the piece there 27.
28 he's definitely going to get 30.
at least
oh or not Bishop takes Knight oh that's
a tricky one
H4 request two yes he does it
and for him 32 in a minute is not even
like his high
33 G7 King G6 good job
the fact that he slows down at times but
is still able to have such a high score
in such short amount of time is just
mind-blowing
that's crazy so far so good he's got 38
okay Rook D1 oh rookie six Check Yes
there you go
and there the King was trapped in the
corner
Rook F6 beautiful 43.
okay now take G7 good job
Bishop takes you oh Queen F6 oh it was
very attempting to take on the 97. see
this is what happens
and then you kind of lose steam it's
Knight F6 Knight D7
wow can he get to 50.
I think so oh Rook E1 it was Queen job
is these kind of slow moves that are
simply not the right move you cannot
make this move but it it's so hard when
you don't see the actual solution so it
just continues
yeah and three strikes it sounds like a
lot but the moment you get one wrong you
already feel like you're oh email slips
there Queen G7 of course was the move
it is so hard to keep up this pace
throughout the entire 30 minutes because
at some point you just get exhausted I
know from experience when I do puzzle
rushes for a long time I just get
extremely exhausted and it's really hard
to keep up that pace
um after such a long time
you're right sometimes you don't even
realize how tired you are and then you
realize that you just
start getting
the you know the teen problems wrong and
that's when you know your brain your
brain is is starting to run on empty
but so far Andrew I mean he is such a
resilient bullet player he can play
hours and hours of bullet without losing
too much speed
so I think that'll serve him very well
in the context of this tournament
indeed wow 96 was super tempting they're
forking into King and Rook but he saw
the checkmate
remaining that there
Queen F5 win the queen
discovery
yeah mate
you know it's sometimes easy to see the
first move but then the second move you
actually haven't really calculated it or
you didn't expect your opponents move
and you're like okay wait what
yeah sometimes you're also basically
pre-moving in Puzzle Battle and then you
and then you face an unexpected move
very tilting situation no Rook F1
okay where's the mate oh where's the
mate you gotta activate bishop and he
does it wow that was tough before wins
the bishop
take no no no no no he was hanging on
before oh wait oh he he had a third
mistake there
aye aye oh he's got to be careful
because this is how you you dig yourself
into a hole but only five minutes have
elapsed so plenty of time here to get a
good run-in
but you can already start seeing the
first signs of fatigue by some of these
players you know just a little bit less
consistent
than usual
yeah he's still solving them very very
quickly but you can see there's a little
bit slippery going on there with the
mouse and
um he's trying to play really really
fast but it could lead to a mouse lip
very easily
it's tough for him to decide where to go
with your king yeah
difficult batch here but he gotta gets a
couple made in ones to boost his score
might be three and A3
take the queen
oh sacrificing The Rook for that That's
a classic one where you have to pursue
the white king all the way up the board
and prevent it from
reaching the uh
the appropriate file no take the bishop
oof
but are you still going on
um
Queen A1 Quincy three finds it
oh
on track on the clock oh yeah
push the pawn will you promote first and
find the right Square
yeah every Square was protected
otherwise you have to take the pawn so
you promote with check oh oh queen of
force seems good why didn't he do it
okay
I guess King D4 there yeah no the move
was Queen takes G7 and E5 mate very
difficult oh what
now what
what is this Knight G3 no
I don't see it
I don't see it either what
I guess it was an ig3
wow oh Knight G3 and Rook takes Bishop
because the Rook on H1 would be defended
wow that was a tough one
but how are you dealing with the Palm D7
well The Rook on D2 stops it because you
take division you're not taking it okay
yeah but it's that was insane
yeah crazy
okay so seven minutes
let's see what Rey has has his eye
scores we have the uh current top
scorers on the left side of your screen
okay molecular chemist has 55.
wow that's a huge score
not sure who that is
someone who's good at puzzles I guess
looks like it
by George Baba also in there vidit as
you said
um
some of those names are not familiar to
me it's really awesome to see that these
people are also participating getting a
chance to qualify to knock out bracket
um and yeah we'd love to see new faces
shine as well
yeah but Andrew he's struggling right
now he's he's kind of tilting and he's
in the semi-tilt mode where he's a
little bit too sloppy in the First
puzzles and
if you're someone like Andrew you have
to get the first 30 correct
you just have to you can't make any
mistakes in the first minute
he's really really fast but the accuracy
we're needing we're in need of more
accuracy here
it's really tough to ask
24 you'll get to 30 this time and then
maybe we'll check into somebody else
oh the pawn was uh was just promoting
[Music]
so many notifications
what is that sound I don't know that's
something from his computer I guess
it's playing too fast computer
overheating
yeah I never I mean the amount of tabs
that he has open would give me like
massive anxiety
[Music]
this time it's not too bad I've seen
much worse oh yeah you can actually see
the like names of the websites
Queen D4 take the Rook Knight on 596.
Rook takes
but now what check 87 yeah seven
you have to take credit or A7 you
promote oh wow Rook takes B1 now Queen
D2 no I guess it is Queen D2 it is Queen
D2
no I don't know it's hard
and then we'll check into Rey afterwards
wow bad door has 53. huge score by
Chicago
not bad at all
incredible Christopher you struggling
thus far
45 minutes
30 seconds left
yeah that was a that was a wasted run
right there let's go to right I want to
see some Ray Robinson action here we go
all right 10 minutes elapsed 20 minutes
to go in this batch
we're watching it's so easy yeah
totally casual C3 C3
uh Ray's having a blind spot he sees it
then
okay
takes Bishop C6 a little bit too casual
here so far
yeah let's see if he speeds up
yeah he's he's pretty um he's taking it
very easy over here
yeah I mean he knows that he can get
like 53 on demand basically so
King D3
I don't know I rate he isn't feeling as
confident as he normally is that was a
tricky one though
yeah
okay
B5 and queen D7
now a little ladder made action
I think King takes oh King takes just to
prevent any sort of check
that one he got instantly Bishop E4
what yeah but
that's what we talked about initially
he's casual but when he gets to the 40s
he doesn't slow down like most people he
actually just speeds up
foreign
look at this
queen takes F7 and oh wow this should be
five It's gotta be that oh 95. wow
F6 what I'm not even registering what's
going on
look at this he's gonna get 50.
oh my gosh G5 G5 no it's back to H6 oh
not even
no this is this is illegal this is
ridiculous
A4 maybe no what it is takes
I mean some of this you must know that
there's just no way
I think it's here in rookie two
Bishop E4 no
doesn't work
how is he seeing all of this queen C4
oh my gosh
I thought that was Checkmate oh we got
55. oh my God I feel like I got a lot
wow okay I got to 50 five I'm not who
the heck is Philippians 46.
[Laughter]
I honestly have no words
yeah this is insane and as he said he
did get many difficult ones
oh my gosh okay and he's not satisfied
he wants 57 58 he wants to be number one
right now
55 Almost Doesn't get you into the top
two which is crazy
wow
okay this format is interesting in a way
that the top two advances and doesn't
really compete the next round I believe
so
um the stronger Ones Will basically
um get removed from the next rounds
pretty much yeah
no it's true
and you promote stopping white from
promoting That's a classic Puzzle Battle
Theme puzzle Rush theme where you
have simultaneous promotion but one side
promotes with diagonal control over the
other promotion Square
that's an easy one okay this time he's
got a more manageable batch
34. oh wow 81 mate
hey oh
I hate those where you have to run
around to their king and you don't know
where you're going G5
and you just take the pawn and run very
nice smoothly executed there too with
the mouse yes
gotta be careful there
classic Manning net
see these are the ones that are just
brutal oh yep
how did he do that so fast
finding a safe Square for your king okay
he's got 46 he's about to have 47 in a
minute to go he's got a chance for 55
here again yes
my gosh Bishop B4
love that what yep I just thought Bishop
takes C3 was sufficient but you just
take back with the queen what is this
this is like a positional exercise oh my
rookie won girl that was insane
Queen C4 and Rook B4 and Rook B throw oh
my God it would be one wow
Castle
unbelievable he's got 54. he's got 30
seconds left this is a huge run
oh 27
no it's okay one
55.
take G6 no it's no
56. can he get 57 in the top score
yes he can
wow
oh my gosh A4 oh my God that was Rook G1
oh we got 58
no way
that's his best today right there
and it's just a sip of water just very
casual another day in the office
I wonder if he's not going to take a
joke or if he's going to
get a better score
58 I would just retire from just the
tournament
and I would just call up all my friends
and and now he's analyzing he's like why
didn't I get this one correct it's I
wonder what the move is in this position
it's probably Rook G1
yeah must be and then you got your Rook
to G7 as well and he's upset that he
didn't get this one the guy got 58 and
he's like why didn't I get this one
right
I mean hindsight of course uh you see
this puzzle and you're like yeah like
he's so that's such a pace he's not
speeding up too much so there is some
room to analyze the position like in a
brief moment but
um he's not playing that fast
in a way
like he rarely Mouse slips
yeah
I wish I could have this uh you know
space consistently because if I don't
have like a very nice run uh where I do
like uh I don't know like 20 25 in a
minute it's going downhill very quickly
um so being able to have this pace
throughout the entire puzzle Rush run is
really really great
yeah
incredible he's basically guaranteed
top scorer in round two I I just do not
if anybody gets over 58 then
then I I retire from commentating like
that
I don't think I don't think I mean
Philippians 46 I've never seen him
before I don't remember him in previous
editions of the uh PR World Championship
so clearly another big name on the scene
he might get number two at this rate
yeah crazy scores and you still uh he's
not continuing
nope he's just sitting there I I don't
know if he even wants to continue I mean
you can see the scoreboard just updated
there
he is now in first place
and I think as Rey is taking his time we
could switch to the stream of Alexander
boardnick
who needs to up his game because he's
currently sitting at 45 and
in the bottom three
here he goes
I tried looking up who Philippians 46 is
but the only information I got is that
he's part of a club called Pro puzzle
solvers team so the name says enough
yeah clearly someone who knows his worth
in regards to Puzzle Battle boardnick
with a good run
let's see how far he can go
Queen A1 Bishop E5 40.
another three foreign
s are not too bad you take 94. oh he
missed it yep you're absolutely right
that was the line 93 yep just checkmate
we get to 50.
nice one Queen B3 Queen takes D5 and
Rook f8 oh nice one
night E3 but two nights is that enough
yeah you had to find a way to defend the
pawn there I don't know how
I guess it was Knight C8 oh my gosh
insane move
oh he might not get to 50.
good stuff 49.
oh beautiful he is gonna get to 50.
96. most correct move
you know the bottom three has really
high scores the last place is 4 on 49
and the others have 50. so you need to
score higher in order to not get
eliminated yeah Jeffrey and board Nick
right now they need to try to get 5152
and they've got two or three runs left
before the next round is over 10 minutes
on the time remaining clock
ah Queen
almost a slip you got it right
okay nice one
he's jumping to his music
yeah having a good time that's what we
like to see
I love this song
so I don't know what song is this it's
Queen Show Must Go On
oh
never heard of it
no I know Queen the only song by Queen
that I know is um
wait is uh that song
what is that how does that song go can't
stop me
is that stuff we know yeah can't stop me
now
yeah that's that's the only Queen song I
know but you don't know Bohemian
Rhapsody oh well we even obviously is
famous okay
Rhapsody I know
but in high school I was I was hopeless
now I know a lot of like music
references
uh well it's because my parents uh made
me grow up with this music so yeah
that's good that's good I mean I I
really only started listening to music
in high school
like I listen to classical music but
I started listening to popular music in
high school so before that I I had zero
knowledge of any references like I
didn't know Britney Spears was you know
and we are the champions We Are the
Champions is by Queen as well yeah yeah
yeah there's a lot of uh great songs by
Queen that was too easy
although that's one of those songs you
don't really listen to in its entirety I
feel like you only listen to it at
events like yes yep
so
in other news uh Bortnick is on 41 but
only 38 seconds left now is he going to
make it to 51 perhaps oh what was that
that was a very bad move there by Sasha
he's not gonna make it to 50 this time
okay okay don't be wrong
okay
wow repeat six
okay he did get to 49 but it's still not
enough okay and we'll take a look at the
scoreboard very shortly but
it seems to me that 51 might end up
being the minimum score
probably yeah and there we see it the
scoreboard and indeed 51 right now is
sufficient to advance but it's getting
really close and that's we have seven
minutes left on the match clock anything
can still happen and I'm kind of worried
even for those that have 51 right now
yeah yeah no it's it's a log Jam in the
low 50s obviously Ray and Philippians
looks like they're gonna take the top
two spots and qualify
the bottom three get eliminated and then
the 15 in between have to move on to the
next round where the same process rinses
and repeats ad nauseam
okay he's gonna quit this run
currently 50 does qualify though
oh no it doesn't sorry bottom three are
eliminated right right you have you need
to get 51 right now
let's take another look I feel like I'm
looking at the airport departures board
trying to look for my flight
okay so you're right 50 does not qualify
bad for Life Jeffrey and shock spieler
are not gonna make it unless they score
51 at least min
got 51 and Andrew Tang has managed 52 so
they make it to the next round as it
currently stands
I don't know about you Diana but I
recognize more players than the bottom
10 than in the top 10.
oh yeah totally same yeah
they got Philippians and I don't know
any of those people are
oh not afraid that's a famous song
okay you know I know a lot of songs but
not this one
yeah this one I've actually heard on
some people's streams
okay
all right
let's get into Jeffrey's young stream
for the rest of the uh
for the rest of the five minutes that we
have in round two here at The Puzzle
Battle World Championship
Jeffrey is currently
on 49 I think so he needs a big run in
the last four minutes
and he's struggling what is happening
he is I think
there we go okay
this is a this is a chance this is the
one
this is the one
here he goes
back rank back rank check me checkmates
Checkmate
also Checkmate another checkmate
there's like a background mate another
one wait I haven't seen so many
checkmates in a row yeah that this is
where you build up big scores right
these when you get like 10 or 15 puzzles
in a row like that even that was
checkmate
what so far so good 20 in only 30
seconds
we need five
take the queen yep
Knight takes
oh wow because the queen was hanging
oh Bishop takes first to take the Rook
wow
yeah it's Bishop takes
okay I mean the queen he's got 30.
oh man he's going lightning speed I
think you take the bishop and go F6
looks like it
yeah Rook B7 easy clap very clean
it was correct it was correct oh let's
um oh
yeah let's go back to our forward View
we've got Ray Jeffrey we've got Bortnick
and Tang on the top left
and Andrew Tang has had a 51 Point run
so I think he's gonna make it to the
next round
yeah it looks like it
important still on his run 42 he does
have some time left
there he goes we're gonna check into
board Nick once again two minutes 30
seconds left in round two
and only a little bit more time for the
players in the bottom three
to qualify Jeffrey is at a very tough
goal but looks like his highest they're
only 39.
but it does appear that his mind might
be divided
oh what do you do here 95 but then
what's next oh well wow 28 48 and no
strikes oh my gosh this might be a big
one for board Nick
55 on the second move okay B3 this is
easy
51.
Rook C8
Queen D3 he's gonna get 52. yes he does
it
53.
what is this one nope yeah you're right
54. okay
and to beat Philippians Bishop C6 can he
get 55 no no he can't
qualified
yes 54. wow but wait it's only one oh my
god oh it's made
oh no I totally totally
um I feel that viscerally
all right that was a really good run
oh
wow it's one one made of 56
and two people 55 wow no no chances no
not even close actually
Liam putt number 55. insanity
that's that's sick
but this run was very crucial because
now he is secured to advance the next
round which is really important the
bottom three will be eliminated and it
does appear unless anything changes in
the last 30 seconds that bad for Life
shock spieler and Jeffrey
are going to be eliminated unless they
can come come up with a 51 Point run
in the waning seconds here 20 seconds
left on the ticker
this run will count for Andrew Tang if
you start the run in with any time
remaining it does count but Ray Robson
is the king and he proves that again and
again and again 58 is the top score in
round two for Ray Robson
with Philippians close behind on 56.
yeah so 56 or 57 will uh guarantee you
to play tomorrow's in tomorrow's uh
final knockout bracket but yep you still
have a lot of attempts possible and I
don't think it will be too bad to uh
have Ray wraps in advance already and
then you can try the next round again
yeah yeah
okay and there's a ray we're cutting
away to his stream
Knight F5
no Knight G3
I think I should already do let Ray do
the talking he's gonna get another big
run he's got 50 with with him with about
a minute
we are slowing down a little bit now
it's getting tougher
or is it not for Ray for us normal
people it would be getting tougher
that's right
A2 oh wow no no no oh you win The Rook
in the end oh wow that's massive
how is he doing this oh he taken then go
B2 and you can't stop the pawn
oh look at this run to end round two
he's gonna get at least 55.
if you can get this one right what
what did I just witness 56
Bishop B3 Bishop E3 wins and queen H2 93
so oh
57 it's gonna be oh
so you need a solution oh this literally
would have been the top score if he
himself hadn't gone 58.
that's it
that's it I don't think this run is
gonna count for Andrew I think this or
maybe it is
I believe it's the same one
it might be the same one and Philippians
um we have gone word of who that is let
me confirm that we can actually share
that information
but uh it's he's a very strong player
I'll put it that way for now
yeah so I'm not entirely surprised at
his score
and that was the last one before Andrew
Tang
wow there we go what a finish
and that ladies and gentlemen concludes
round two we unless somebody got a crazy
score in the last seconds we know that
Ray Robson and Philippians 46 have
qualified into tomorrow's knockout they
their run for today is over they can go
relax huge scores all around in the top
10 55s 54s and unfortunately the bottom
three there uh who are grayed out they
are going home with two hundred dollars
but their run comes to an end and the 15
players in between for molecular
chemists to Slippery Speedster will have
to dip their toes back into the pool and
repeat in round three so nmi are gonna
have the same drill the top two scores
in round three qualify the bottom three
are eliminated and we will continue
bringing you commentary here from the
puzzles World Championship we'll be back
with round three in just a couple
minutes
foreign
dude it's impossible to not hear you
just breathing super loudly okay fine I
will hold my breath for three minutes
all right let's go okay let's go right
now
right here almost there and you did it
what can you do for three minutes my
wife says not a lot but I can play keep
that big butt down dude nice
two one you did it wow I feel better oh
yeah oh you were timing me yeah you were
in there for 30. oh man let's play some
chess and get some dinner let's do it
time lines yeah okay you bring a clock
oh I left my clock at home dude you
idiot I told you to bring it let's just
go get something to eat okay
download the new chess.com clock app so
you can time yourself playing chess or
whatever other dumb stuff you and your
friends do
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
check it out
three two one
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the puzzles world
championship this is day one of this
epic event we're just getting started
and we've already had enough
entertainment to last a lifetime I'm GM
Daniel nerdinsky alongside women's
International Master anamaya Kazarian
anamaya it's been super entertaining
thus far we've already had some epic
individual runs most of them coming at
the hands of Grand Master Ray Robson
all right Dania welcome back everyone we
saw Ray Robson hitting the Fantastic
score of 58 in a three minute puzzles
that is not a joke and he will now
advance to tomorrow's final knockout
bracket we will continue with another 30
minute segment of uh puzzle Russia's
three minute once uh we have 15 players
left and again the top two will advance
to tomorrow's knockout bracket Diane and
the bottom three are unfortunately
eliminated we've already had a couple uh
players eliminated but the prizes are
very generous even those players are
limited to take home a cool 200 bucks I
think the total prize fund is 25 G's so
everybody's gonna get a little bit of
something some players are gonna get a
lot of something but when you're
watching these 58 Point runs 56 Point
runs it's absolutely mesmerizing how
fast the players solve the difficult
problems I also wanted to point out and
Maya that Philippians 46 the second
place finisher who also makes his way
directly into tomorrow's knockout is
none other than International Master
Andy Woodward who I think originally
hails from Texas he is a very promising
young player he's playing all over the
United States recently became
International master and is close to
2500 feet a so Andy he is a household
name at this point among anybody who
plays tournaments of the United States
very very promising young talent and
clearly a ridiculously fast solver
wow what an impressive uh young Talent
um I saw that he's I believe he's from
2010 so he's barely 12 13 years old
crazy yeah Andy's super nice young kid
too very very modest easy to root for I
saw him uh just recently he played in
Charlotte he might be playing again this
weekend so I hope I don't get paired
with him uh especially after his
performance today but the 15 players in
the middle as you said they're gonna
have to earn their ticket through with
the same rules repeating for round three
we will start by watching Alexander
Bortnick try his hand at qualifying he
came Incredibly Close with a 55 Point
run sorry 54 Point run unfortunately
wasn't quite good enough and the ticker
should start any second
rides and the worst part of this format
is that you want to improve your
previous score your previous top score
because if you don't hit this score
again in the 30 minutes then it kind of
feels you know like it it doesn't feel
right you want to keep improving and
that's the hard part because how do you
improve this insane score of 54. again
it just feels deflating and you know
it's almost like uh uh data data plans
on the phone where I only use one
gigabyte but it doesn't roll over you
have the same limit in the next segment
so the 54 points you got in the previous
round that's old news that's the
previous month's score you got to do it
from scratch you got to do it again it
does not roll over
and and that can definitely be very
deflating and Amaya because what do you
have to do for Klondike what do you have
to do to get 54 in a puzzle Rush how
many times am I going to have to get it
is what Alexander reporting is probably
thinking right now he might have to get
55 or 56 if he wants to qualify
right and I think the one thing uh
Britney can improve here is I saw that
his animations were still on if he
turned him off that's like a life hack
for puzzle rushes you can solve the
puzzles even faster because the moves
come in really really fast like
instantly and for you know beginners
it's really not recommended because you
you need to see your opponent's moves
but for those players they see this in a
split second and they need this speed
they do indeed that's a great tip
definitely turn the animations off if
you're trying to optimize speed and the
ticker the ticker has started we're
going to have 30 more minutes of solving
and 30 more minutes of competing high
scores here we go Alexander boardnick
starting it off with a bang 10 points in
15 seconds
oh no
okay he's the airplane is back under
control
he's not distracted at all nope
Checkmate Checkmate Oh Oh I thought
Queenie one was like oh he was in check
the queen on C5 was checking the King on
A7
how many title players does it take to
see the check in one move
yeah yeah I mean the easiest way of
finding out is by making a different
move and uh you know Jessica will tell
you it was it's a check
okay
yeah you always feel like such a such a
fool when you make a move and then the
piece blinks like oh you're rude yeah
really yeah thanks for letting me know
could have been nicer about it
yeah some people say check you know you
have you ever made an illegal move in a
OTB game
uh uh I don't think so no I I actually I
played in the world wrapped on Blitz and
I had two opponents making legal moves
and uh one of them was very crucial I
was winning but the illegal move made
like the one easier because it was
automatically gonna be a lost game the
other one was not that lost so I still
have to fight for the win but the extra
time is nice
yeah I mean I think the rules used to be
more harsh in classical chess you used
to Forfeit but they've changed the rules
a couple years ago actually maybe a
couple decades ago because I remember I
played a tournament in 2006 uh and I was
the top seed it was the United States uh
elementary school championship
and I was playing a stick my rating was
2000 I was playing a 1600 and I was
losing I was down a rook and he makes an
illegal move and I called Over The
Arbiter and I was under the impression
that an illegal move loses and he had
told me that I was out of luck because
about a year ago in 2005 the American
chess rules had changed uh from forfeit
to now I only get two minutes I'm like I
don't need two minutes I'm down a rook I
don't care about the two minutes I want
to win so it was bad timing but uh yeah
yeah I guess it's for the best I don't
want to be that harsh on the legal moves
but it has quite often
yeah in Blitz especially but even in
classical you shouldn't illegal move
should not lose the game right you
shouldn't that's not in the spirit in
the spirit of Chess and Bortnick with a
solid first run he's gonna get 49 that
ain't gonna cut it though you need at
least 51 or 52 if you want to qualify or
if you want to avoid elimination rather
yeah yeah it's crazy to say that 50 is
what you need to
um not get eliminated and yeah for some
of us that is uh you know Out Of Reach
um when will I like some some people
have survival runs that barely hit 50 or
it's you know really difficult but these
people get it in three minutes
crazy
yeah yeah it is it is
and he starts off another pretty solid
run here 16 in 30 seconds
and he wants more he's got a couple
checkmates here
to rack up the points
check me don't cheat that was tricky
okay looks good
okay Queen D6 don't go queen d8 that
square was protected yep Rook E8
deflection wow
classic
oh Rook F1 first and then
easy clap
no no no no no Rook G8 Rook G8 Sasha
oh he's listening
and I will be seeing him in just a
couple days I think he's
gonna get on a plane maybe even today
he's playing uh the Charlotte open
ah not looking forward to facing him in
this tournament so I'm gonna do my best
[Applause]
is there someone you may be looking
forward to playing no I nobody not the
kids not board Nick not Andrew Tang
okay then I like old old opponents over
60. that's that's my preferred okay
we're still rooting for a year here just
so you know ah
well I've I've passed the age where most
usually I've done a little calculation
and over half of the opponents in my
last five or six tournaments have been
younger than me so I'm officially old
news
yeah I felt the same when I played in
Dutch championships the Dutch women's
um typically I was the youngest one and
this year I was among the eldest ones
it was not fun that there was uh uh like
half of the participants so we were with
six and three of them were
um 20 years or younger unbelievable
crazy yeah getting younger and younger
yeah well I'm still as addicted to 30
second chess as I was when I was 15 so I
don't know when that's gonna change
[Laughter]
it'll last through my 30s
still going strong
scared even say the word 30. let's not
talk about that
let's talk about boarding hitting 20 now
in less than a minute
let's see if we can keep it up
oh no you've cursed him that you don't
know the fact that you just said that
watch he's gonna get one wrong
I Believe In You Bortnick
grab the wrong piece I think you grabbed
the white piece like no you're playing
Black
oh
Anastasia's mate
okay looking good
oh we have to play very precise there
decide which rock to put on a squirrel
yeah
rookie five lifted up put it down
yeah oh Rook F1
uh King F7 at the end Wednesday oh and
you take the bishop right he's a clap
and then you pursue the king to the edge
of the Earth
Rook takes f8 made in one okay okay
checkmate
queen b71 queen E6 it was very tempting
what the heck is this I think you just
pushed before
no King Jesus looks back
oh wow you need that Tempo to attack The
Rook so you could push your Pawn
40. nice find
mate
oh the Knight is pinned we're gonna wait
for Bortnick to complete this run and
then we're gonna look into Genesis
stream
oh this one is tricky okay
simplify it oh God this is such a
headache it's not King G4 are you
kidding me it's not winning what I guess
it's King G5 you need the opposition
there yeah otherwise king of six comes
in oh Jim has got 57 apparently some
people wow
but we'll confirm that independently
okay
oh what a nice Checkmate pattern
H5 and Knight G2 is mate
51 that's not bad
oh this Knight must be trapped ah that
looks very tempting
and 51 very good score that might ensure
ensure that he doesn't get eliminated
but it might it's definitely not enough
to qualify to qualify you need to be Rey
and gymnast so they might already take
the top two spots
they think too yeah
first few puzzles go by really fast most
sometimes checkmates or huge material
advantages exactly yeah that's why you
need to rack up the score
in the easy ones let's go to Genesis
stream I I've had my my fill of board
Nook let's go to Greece
look at this board can you see it
I mean this is making me feel very old
I have never seen such a small board
this is unbelievable and I get the logic
behind the small board which is that you
it's easier obviously to move from side
to side
but this is insane
are you kidding me right now
I wish I could I could I wish I could
drag the the screen like you know when
you have touch screen you can like drag
it out so you can zoom in exactly I also
want to do it on his behalf
what
how does he even move here like I've
I've made like made my board sometimes a
little bit smaller and I can like sense
my sensitivity of the mouse is just too
much like I cannot do that yo he's his
DPI is clearly insane he's got 51 by the
way and no strikes so
I mean I'm trying to figure out what's
going on on the boards like I I can
barely identify the pieces
um oh no there's a huge overlay on it as
well and he's getting some followers oh
and he promotes the queen and mate
diagonally 53
he's got 57 confirmed oh my gosh and now
he's got another chance at a huge score
I cannot tell the pieces
I mean it should be five notice
impossible the night before Queen
somewhere anywhere put it on a square
oh my gosh
insane
yeah that is a crazy score
um but yeah his top is 57.
and it seems like his strategy is
working for him I really wonder how he's
able to like even identify the pieces at
this stream is like Inception it's like
there's like 50 things that he's opening
at the same time and then he's going
back to the puzzle right like I don't
know how he is able to just like he's
looking at the high scores and then he's
looking at
the rush and now here he goes again
no more runs yeah right I was gonna say
he's on 57 by far first so he doesn't
even need to continue but honestly like
it's nice to practice why not now what's
interesting is I don't see Rey oh Ray
already qualified sorry I forget I
forgot that Ray already made it so
scratch what I said about Rey the people
you really need to beat this time are of
course gymnast and molecular chemists
who was super impressive
um jimis's real name is Demetrius
ladopoulos he is a Greek player he's not
titled he's about 2200 feet a
but he is a bullet expert uh he's about
27 2800 bullet and obviously his claim
to fame is his ability to solve
yeah for those who are wondering this is
uh dimitrios
apologies if I pronounce the name
incorrectly he's thank you he's a female
master from Greece and you might think
wait he's not a grand master no but he
is a very strong Puzzler and that goes
to show you don't need to be a
Grandmaster to be good at puzzle Rush
no and I mean you don't even need to be
a title player and that's honestly the
beauty of it it's like a different form
of the game it's it's really all about
practice
uh and it's all about you know it's it's
all about your pattern recognition and
that always doesn't always translate to
even to Blitz
so he is a strong Blitz player uh
definitely stronger than his fide rating
would indicate
uh so he's very tactically gifted but
again his main calling card is his
puzzle solving ability no question about
it
right he's now on 43 a minute and 15
seconds left so can he clinch it and
make an improvement because my I'm like
my brain is about to melt so let's go
back maybe to Andrew Tang's stream if
that's okay with you anime yeah of
course of course let's go uh we have
Andrew Tang now on uh we can uh we can
identify the pieces here clearly so
that's uh that's very pleasing to see at
least
yeah I feel like the old guy at the
bookstore do you have the same book in
bigger size font
all right and
okay the ticker is obviously we will um
correct that shortly
because we are maybe about 10 minutes
into the round
what is this puzzle oh my no definitely
not promote to a rook
I don't know what the need was for that
there was a stalemate idea with Knight
G3 and Bishop it was promoted to him
Bishop Maybe
no it was just to move the night it was
just to move the Knight and then you
can't stop the pawn okay oh that's tough
yeah I still can't get it
and I've had like 10 minutes to think
about it
here he goes look at that speed insane
Min has been very stable with a high
score of 51 that probably is gonna get
him through
to the next round but really to win the
event you need to be able to get 55-56
pretty consistently
mm-hmm
or what's going on here
[Music]
um
I want to play Queen G4 but it doesn't
feel right no no Andrew Bishop G5
trapped the queen oh sloppy there and
wait as the clock was running down of
the of the Run he was checking real
quick what the standings were yeah I
mean right now I think he's he's safe
Frederick's vein Liam Putnam and
molecular chemist who got the third
highest score
in the first round is really scuffling
here with 15 minutes remaining on the
round three ticker
hmm
penguin has 51. so he's he's already
safe for the most part A lot of people
are on 51 currently with their top score
so
it's getting really close
yep
mate mate mate better mates
pin mate mate mate
hey
mate
I find it more impressive here
identifying the puzzles uh I know I'm
that classifying an anime as he's
solving and this is honestly incredible
commentating display
I would make a sports reference but it's
it's way too obscure
it's fine Bring it on I'm I'm curious
who in the chat remembers uh Joe Buck's
famous call in in American football
Mitchell
Mitchell Mitchell Mitchell there's a
really famous uh
call it's considered a very bad
commentator call from uh the American
football playoffs in 2006. how much time
is left but uh it went viral at the time
so that's what this reminded me of
let's see if I can even get one person
in the chat to know what I was talking
about
yep we got a couple
yeah we got some people uh who remember
it nice
awesome
unfortunately I'm not very into sports I
as much as I do like watching it from
time to time I'm not a huge sports fan
I love sports but I also don't like it
when sports fans guilt people into like
or consider themselves Superior because
they do watch sports you know oh no
definitely so that's why I don't love
sports references because I don't I like
I don't do Sports references to to make
people think that I know a lot it's just
sometimes I think it really is good to
compare chess to other sports moments
but yeah it's fun
but I don't like it when people you know
start referencing obscure sports events
to show how much they know 93 by the way
was the maiden 2.
still going he has a really good score
[Music]
get it together
it's those little mistakes that make the
difference if he could keep that
accuracy going it would be a massive
score oh yeah he's so fast in the first
like minute it's unbelievable but he's
just a little bit too sloppy I would say
in Puzzles number 25 to 35 that's where
he often makes a mistake and you just
cannot afford a mistake before you hit
40 unless you're right
saravan renjit apparently got 53 we're
gonna watch Min Lee
a little bit to see if he can beat his
own score of 51.
there he goes
twirling is there that's a signature
move
the queen is trapped
we'll see things guys I guess you take
on D5 stop
I guess you do and you take back the
queen oh and then DC at the end to pin
the night
I wasn't sure about the material
advantage there it didn't really look
too good but what the hell seems like
it's still correct Queen D5 Queen D4
fork in the two roads this husband's
favorite song by the way Unstoppable by
Sia
I love it I love this song yeah it's a
great song he plays it unlike all of his
important streams which is adorable
does he put it on like
um replay yeah I think so oh that's nice
thank you for the one again
my bed is just keep my little one now
the problem when I do that is the song
gets stuck in my head and then I can't
concentrate
I always have a song stuck in my head
during OTB games
I think it's like
a problem
I mean it's I guess like you want to
have some small fun distraction at the
same time while you're spending hours
behind the chessboard
no exactly it's too much of a drag
otherwise
you guys want some now he's playing
they're most lips I think this is
Chandelier by SIA yep correct they're
Muslims
[Laughter]
take the Rook there don't take the queen
very smooth
right
No rookie eight oh
there's always tricky because you can
always give a check with a queen but the
Rook check is better
yes yeah those those are very tough your
brain tells you one thing and
your uh your hand does another and
that's always dangerous
[Music]
I love this kind of where do you go oh
no not this one this is pretty hot King
F6 I think it's King F6 good job
feels like a Checkmate but all of the
squares were covered pretty much
I mean
taking the queen and promoting first
Knight G5 is a classic
okay
super pretty soft
okay thanks for each one oh okay seven
then yep
um 91.
good job but then what
Bishop G5 at the end okay Queen D2 Rook
a three Queen A5
um
I think you go no my G3 tonight I think
you take the Knight
I think you just take the Knight on F6
men kind of overthinking that one
yeah he don't think he's fast he's very
clean but he might not be fast enough to
get 50 here
bear he did have very long puzzles
no choice sequences brutal yeah
this has been a brutal batch
we saw earlier a run where there were
like the first 20 puzzles we're all
checkmates in one two three moves and
here the the tactics are quite
complicated
for sure
holy Mouse lips he takes F5
not my moment at all
[Music]
23.
what tune in
so unfucking it was rookie two very
counter-intuitive oh
tough one there for men but he's fine
he's got 51 as his high this round
should be enough to qualify into the
next round
seven minutes still left on the match
clock so uh there's still some time
there's still some time just yeah and
just to clarify when I say the word
qualify there's two types if you score
on the top two you qualify to The
Knockout tomorrow otherwise you make it
to the next round where you have to
avoid finishing in the bottom three
right and those that move on that uh
there will be higher prices for them uh
of course tomorrow's final knockout
bracket will have a huge prize fund but
also those that do not get eliminated
also get a little bit more money uh
their price
and money is good
at least something we can all agree on
oh absolutely and there we go 10 in 15
seconds
just like a decent run so far but can
you keep up the pace but look at this
we've got a huge Log Jam of flares with
51 so it all depends on the tie breaks
and
currently Bortnick is in last place so
this is gonna get really close Andrew
tang and Bortnick are both
both stand to be eliminated if they
don't put forward a 52-point run at
least
wow wow particularly comments on 56.
look at that in my there's a seven-way
tie for players who scored 51. seven
people have a high score of 51.
and Min does have good tie breaks as it
currently stands
wow
scores are so close and I feel like as
we go on in the rounds it gets even
closer because the really top players
are advancing and then we still have
those players that are really close
together
yeah and that's where the Intrigue
really lies molecular chemists by the
way he's gonna make it through most
probably as is jimus
but you can see there round accident
and Alexander Bortnick
stand to get eliminated unless
they can do something big in the last
five minutes
oh man is struggling I want to say that
maybe we can pull up Andrew tank stream
or Borton extreme because they are the
ones who actually need to score higher
than 51.
let's look at board Nick
34. that's not a bad score but will he
be able to keep up the pace
that's important and avoid frustration
because frustration starts to build when
you know that you're basically about to
be limited what is this insane too but
ah okay yeah reflection
what queen F6
yeah the lobster pincer
no he's not going to get 50 though way
too slow this time those puzzles are
really tough though what extremely Queen
A1 oh nice and taking only two going and
taking can you take on do you see six
yeah good good job
okay 40.
that was a 30s puzzle what insane it's
much harder than the ones that you got
afterward and now he's just gotta take
some risks he's got to go really fast
but he's obviously not gonna get I don't
see him getting over 50 this time 50
foot and four he's trying
come on come on do something King H6
no I jinxed him oh no yeah this is not
happening
when the queen 46 but he's got only 10
seconds left and three and a half to go
he's got time for basically one or maybe
two more runs
depending on how it goes
here he goes currently in last place by
tie breaks
two more chances remember if you start a
run with any time left on the overall
ticker clock it counts
restart
no I guess he's got time to finish this
one
he does but it's getting really close
and I'm not sure if you're willing to
risk it
if he gets well he's wrong then at that
point you can basically quit
yeah
okay
mate
okay another Checkmate he's a little bit
too slow in the first minute I think
that's been one of his issues you really
need to try to get 30 in a minute if you
if you want to set yourself up for a 53
54 Point run not that I know I've only
done it once in five years so don't take
my word for it no you're absolutely
right
um the thing that is hurting him most is
really the animations if you turn them
off it goes much quicker much smoother
and those top players really need to
turn it off in order to have a higher
score because that is the main
difference between
um you know like importing having 451
and he he could he has the ability to
have a higher score he's strong he is a
very experienced player he knows his
tactics but the time is a problem here
one of the best bullet players in the
world and that obviously Transit you're
absolutely right though when it gets up
to this level we're talking seconds
every second as valuable every half a
second is the difference between 51 and
52 and that is the difference between
qualifying and getting eliminated and I
don't think he's cutting it this time
either
Bishop C2 or Bishop takes B1 and queen
C2 yep
no not fast enough
yeah and as the puzzles become more
difficult they also tend to become
longer so you also need a lot of time
for them even though you know the
solution
she's speeding up a little bit but 43
okay Queen takes F5 and a rook D1 Rook
D1
gotta go faster nice one 44.
45 okay
what is this what a mess I confess
b5.7 no there's a mate on F2
he needs to give checks
yep no he's not gonna get it no not this
one these are
5th 48
no that's mathematically impossible
and he has time for one more run 20
seconds on the ticker he's got to
restart ASAP
come on all right restart
he's gonna get eliminated he needs to
try again what is he doing he's just
sitting there
oh no somebody tell him to restart he's
lost hope
oh oh my God three seconds two seconds
he has to click the button yeah no he
didn't do it oh no no I can't it's like
too hard oh my gosh I guess he just
didn't believe that he could get higher
than 50 or he just assumed that this was
his final run this was all he could do
ah it appears that he's gonna get
eliminated
by tie breaks because you mentioned that
the tie break is the longest streak how
many did you get right in a row in your
highest drawing
yeah as we can see these are the scores
for round three so the bottom three
Bortnick Andrew tang and Abby Dobby are
eliminated
um rather surprising knowing that Andrew
Tang is one of the fastest players uh
out there but he didn't make it to the
next stage just a little bit too sloppy
and raunak sedwani was standing to be
limited in one of his final runs he
managed 54 points so he lives to fight
another day Jameson molecular chemist
Advanced to tomorrow's knockout that
leaves us with only 10 players remaining
so the field continues to tighten and we
rinse and repeat in the next round the
top two qualify the bottom three are
eliminated until we have no players left
we hope you're enjoying day one of the
puzzles World Championship there's more
action to be had today and tomorrow so
do not go anywhere we will be back with
round four of day one on the other side
of this short break
what's the best way to follow any chess
event from the World Chess Championship
to the candidates the speed chess
championship title Tuesday and so much
more
chess.com events has all of the top
chess tournaments played both over the
board and online
and review games from the world's
greatest players with live commentary
cloud analysis opening Explorer and
table bases find all the key event
information including schedules prizes
results news reports player bios tie
breaks and more
even compete by voting for your
predicted results
explorechess.com events today on web or
with our IOS and Android apps and
experience chess like never before
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the puzzles World
Championship women's I am annamaya
Kazarian Jim Daniel nerdinski bringing
you a commentary today we are ready for
round four a bunch of players have
already been eliminated and a bunch have
made it through to tomorrow's knockout
let's go over the format One More Time
anime there are 30 minutes solving
segments where you're essentially trying
to get as high of a score as you can
only your top score counts
yes Daya and the top two finishers
advance to tomorrow's Puzzle Battle
knockout bracket so that is very
exciting and the bottom three gets
eliminated so you really want to get
into the top uh there uh but of course
if you're uh not eliminated you keep
going and there's a total of five rounds
we're in round four though so you may
want to uh improve your scores a bit
more to advance yeah the field continues
to thin out and we have some crazy news
which is that Andrew Tang as we look at
the overall prizes uh you can see that
there's a 25 000 prize fund but Andrew
Tang this is the important bit of news
he had a run at the very end that he
started with two seconds left on the
match clock it was verified it counted
and he managed to squeak through by
getting 52 His Highest total in the last
run of the allotted time so Andrew Tang
avoids elimination he squeaks through
much to the bad news of the player who
actually does does get eliminated but
Andrew Tang what an incredibly clutch
performance and CM rui uh CM rui
unfortunately does not make it through
she gets eliminated
and uh Andrew Tang lifts to fight
another day
it was insane we were watching it during
the break what is going on is he going
to make it he was very close he had like
a minute left when he was around 50 but
he was so careful and conscious he knew
that he had to hit 52 right there and
just in the final seconds he hit it and
that was it that was a massive clutch
and he continues to play in this event
honestly just an unbelievable
performance uh by some of these players
so impressive how they how they're able
to perform so consistently from round to
round but we remind you that your scores
reset from round to round so even if you
got 57 in the first round congrats you
made it through but you gotta do it
again in the next round the scores do
not roll over jimmus and molecular
chemist have made it through to
tomorrow's knockout but roundocks edwani
Min Lee badur jababa who's been putting
through 54 pretty consistently of course
Christopher you one of the top puzzlers
in the World's End one of the brightest
young talents in the U.S all of these
players will be contesting two more
qualifying spots as we get into round
four
right and we see the scores Jimmy's with
57 molecular chemists with 56 we see
that you need to get those kind of
scores in order to qualify for
tomorrow's knockout and that's not easy
I'm really looking forward to see who
will be next now as Jimmy's on molecular
Arts bands they will not be playing in
round four so who are your picks now who
do you think has the best chances here
well I'm pretty shocked about George
Baba's performance I mean he's part of
the older generation but he's a great
bullet player super fast and I
definitely want to see if we could check
into his stream uh to see what his magic
recipe is but if I had to predict who
qualifies I'll say Christopher you I'm
going to predict a big score for him I
think he might manage 54-55 and uh by
the way Liam putting them very exciting
young fide master from the US also
putting through a consistent 53-54 from
round to round so definitely someone to
keep an eye on as well
right and I remember from previous
editions that uh some of the players
love using their a tablet instead of you
know a desktop or you know a laptop
where they use the mouse in order to
play uh how do you feel do you think it
really makes a difference how do you
feel about playing on touch screen
versus on a computer with a mouse I'm
not good at all I first of all I'm very
bad at Blitz and bullet on my phone I
just I feel like my fingers kind of
block the board I've tried solving on an
iPad and to me I'm just old school I
like to do it on a computer with a nice
Mouse but you know we saw jimus uh
solving on a board that's one millimeter
by one millimeter so I guess each player
has their own method and that's the
beauty of it
right yeah I I noticed that if you have
a decent sized touch screen it can make
the difference uh because you're just
moving the piece around with your with
your fingers whereas you also need to
have a mouse when you're playing on your
desktop so it can make the difference
but each person has their own
preferences and it's really awesome that
we're able to see uh what they're doing
exactly uh as you mentioned uh seeing
Jimmy's play on such a small board is
really awesome to see honestly for sure
and we should be getting underway very
shortly here for round four uh another
30 minutes to get as high of a score as
the players can manage
and we will be as usual looking from
stream to stream unfortunately Alexander
Bortnick has been eliminated but Andrew
Tang has managed to survive to fight
another day so we will start on his
stream and then jump around maybe we'll
see Liam Putnam and battery so we've got
our picks we've got our menu of options
yes yeah this event is so exciting and
to see Bortnick get eliminated you don't
see her too often he is the champion in
Arena Kings entitled Tuesday he plays in
those events so often and we see them at
the top of the leaderboards often but
today he it was not his day
um as there's so many strong players
playing in this event and we're now
listening in to minlay we are listening
into men lay we can start on his stream
uh he managed 53 uh in the previous
round so he's actually improving as he
goes along and really the players who
don't solve regularly they really
benefit from this format because they
get a chance to warm up uh in the first
couple of rounds and now Min is being a
lot more consistent a lot faster
okay let's see here yeah should get
underway here in 20 seconds
the ticker will start the runs will be
official
and Min Lee will try to stay alive
as we kick off round four
yeah it's almost that you are forced to
hit 50 in this event if you're not
hitting 50 you're out
yeah and I think at this point probably
the minimum qualifying score will be 51
or 52. okay here we go let's get this
started
survive here I think so unless or not
[Laughter]
yeah we're just vibing to the music now
but it should start any moment
um as a reminder the players are playing
three minute puzzle rushes in 30 minutes
so okay it seemed like the match clock
is starting there we go
we're underway let's start with minlay
stream
and speed accuracy precision all of that
is so important and we've got a couple
back rank mates to start it off looks
like a pretty promising patch with
Maiden ones Galore pork
you can't move the work
okay nice Checkmate Bishop C5 followed
been very smooth so far
yep me
so far a pretty straightforward patch
Queen G1 and queen G4 picks up the
bishop oh
very neat bishop and he will manage 30
or so in the first minute that's exactly
the kind of start that you want to get
off to another mate
and you will get 30.
Rook back to H6 but does he see the pin
oh wow
that's a very tricky one
he compensates with a couple quick ones
take that and Rook takes G4 take it in
Rook G8
gotta be very precise
a lot of King hunting going on and you
win the queen at the end or you win the
bishop
push H7 I think
and a rook takes 67s
yeah that was that was tough
okay still a pretty decent run to start
it off you might manage 50.
and C3 made at the end
nice easy Queen F7
what's going on just push went into oh
G6 to block B5 and Bishop A6 oh
that was incredible
come on take the bishop I guess
Queen a three
try to set up amazing must be it Queen
A4 it's a nice
chocolate yeah it definitely was Queen
A3 just
like the night and go 95.
yep 26 no Quincy five now
Queen D6 and C4 I wouldn't I just want
to go for Queen these things so just to
cut up some squares
oh 45 to start it off but plenty of time
to improve
that was a good run and he tends to heat
up actually in the second half like he
often starts with a couple mid 40s but
then when push comes to shove I think
Min really knows how to deliver
yeah and his speed is very very good uh
he keeps up this pace throughout and
he's pretty accurate but in the final
ones he had some slips there so let's
see if he can improve his score uh
because here in this field 50 is a
requirement already
yep
okay 26 Knight C7
this one is pretty tricky
okay
or the queen rather
Rook B2
I love men's Hype music I love it it's
exactly the type of music you need
during this for sure for puzzle Rush
yeah yeah
oh wait I guess there's a little glitch
so he refreshed
he's back at it again
yes
it's Rook takes D6 and rookie seven oh
wow Knight G3 Knight F5
G6 oh no H6 first very very accurate
there nicely done
Brook D1
G4
yeah just take and take yep okay he's
got 40 with plenty of time it's H7 and
Rook H1 yep
you get an F6
yep take it take it take it
and this is why he's hesitating
[Music]
okay this is a
oh wow
I don't know what pieces I guess you
play Bishop takes D2 I bet I don't know
yeah that was that was a tough one I'm
not really considering that well I can
feel that
is pretty right here F3 how do you
determine I guess H3 so there's no check
and G4 yeah and okay seven but we're got
54 just now by the way
wow he's insane
that's a huge score
that puts him at the top currently
yeah and it's not easy to beat
we'll check into his stream next
I guess we can finish wait for a minute
to finish this run can he manage 50.
oops no no no that's wrong oh my
goodness oh it's Queen 68.
oh and he doesn't manage 50 but only six
minutes have elapsed
okay here's bador
let's watch the magician in action
oh my god this piece that I find it so
hard to tell the piece apart yeah he
likes these pieces I he plays with them
in Blitz Games as well
oh my well that was oh it's Queen
just when we tune in
approach you won
he is so fast
wait he already has 31 that's a great
score no I'm I'm very impressed with
Butter's speed and his Mouse skills I
mean he is very smooth
yeah very smooth so far at least yes sir
fangirl in the chat is saying that it
looks like a battle drop off is also
using this smaller board and indeed it
looks very minimized and look at
Frederick's vein getting 56 beating bad
words top scorer so Frederick's van
basically just guaranteed qualification
right there wow I did not realize he was
a puzzle a puzzle expert of this
magnitude and a mouse slip
unfortunate yeah we tune in invador but
at this point he's I think he's lost a
little motivation because he has 54. he
knows he's going to qualify
yeah it's really hard to beat that uh
and once again the bottom three gets
eliminated and the chances of getting
eliminated with a score of 54 really
small chances
yeah but I guess you won't get
eliminated this round but you also might
not qualify to the top two because
Frederick's vein has already taken the
top spot and someone like Christopher
you could put in 55 points that's
conceivable mm-hmm so you don't want to
relax if you're bad or
exactly and wow he's he's solving them
at lightning speed wow
and some of the players have dropped a
little bit you know the fatigue you
mentioned this anime early on how people
get tired you don't even notice it but
your scores start declining and look at
those bottom scores right now a lot of
players are really struggling to perform
consistently including Andrew Tang he's
got a high score of 27.
yeah I'm pretty sure he's uh he's on a
better run now uh so we should have his
updated score soon but
um yeah it's it's those first puzzle of
runs I mean they've played so many
puzzle rushes now they've been playing
for almost two hours
um over two hours that is so that's
that's a lot of puzzle rushes I feel
tired and I haven't even solved a single
puzzle so I can't even imagine how they
must feel
what I'm doing
taking Rook G8
wow
oh yeah no no no no Bishop takes C5
check
let me check
okay here he goes
that sound is very satisfying
the one thing I really really like about
puzzles and this might be really strange
is the sounds you get from chess.com
when you have like captures like tick
tick tick tick that sound is just so
satisfying oh it totally is no you're
not strange at all
the last couple runs
oh
we traba got 51. but right now badur
score is enough to to qualify him
directly into the knockout
it seems like Andrew Tang did get 55 so
that might give him the second place as
of now uh if that is indeed true so
that'll be in a huge uh a huge score for
Andrew Tang
okay
55 there we go beautiful speed
performance and bador now has more
motivation because 54 no longer gonna
directly seat him into tomorrow oh come
on
now we want to remind those who just
joined that a lot of players have
already qualified jimis and Ray Robson
have not been eliminated they have
already qualified to tomorrow so they
don't need to solve any more puzzles
that's it
yeah we will see them back tomorrow in
action in The Knockout bracket very
excited for that too God Andrew Tang
it's just such a beast
he barely qualifies
and now puts in 55. he's a queen an
amazing score
yeah
rookie six
no one G6 when the queen
Maybe
Queen B5 good job there Rook after two
complete
E6
wait he's on 42 right now this is a big
score with a minute 15 left he's got to
get this one Knight takes E3
yeah that one was easy
down and he manages to get it
eight yeah 46. I don't think it's Bishop
F2 yeah it's Queen F2 crazy
three or queen C7 Rook C6 mate
um
wow he got on so fast it's a stick
what
noise
the Knight B3 would have had 50. it's
such a dirty way
F2 F2 F2
take yep
no it's king A7
[Music]
[Laughter]
yeah crazy
those puzzles that they're so tilting
when the
um the puzzle makes a move that is so
unpredictable or you just didn't expect
it and then your whole plan is in
shambles or you free moved which is what
battery did there or done the equivalent
of pre-moved like oh no
I've been mouth slipping a lot here
can he get 55 even 55 might not qualify
him then it'll be up to the tie breaks
between him and Andrew
oh Liam Putnam by the way he's building
building up a good score maybe we could
switch to Liam's stream at some point
yeah I would love to have a look at
Liam's score how he's doing oh I jinxed
him he had a huge run going but getting
a couple wrong
unfortunate
we're still watching we're still trying
yeah
it's very impressive to seem so fast oh
that was uh that was a queen blunder
that was not checkmate at all I think
that's a good transition for for uh for
us to go to Liam putnam's stream feed a
master Liam Putnam from New York very
talented player and
clearly a very Advanced puzzle solver
Krista for you by the way
with a score of 54 and chababa continues
to drop down
right now min needs to step it up 50
will not cut it
yeah that's that's wild and yeah let's
see can Liam improve his score here so
he his top scorer is currently at 51. so
he is currently safe but 51 is really
really uh tight yeah at the bottom you
could totally see someone like Min
getting 52 and then
immediately Liam would stand to be
eliminated so
he also has a pretty small board Queen
takes F1 is Main and one
foreign
yep that's a nice little Fork there
um
it's not G3
it was coming H4 it was Queen H4 it
wasn't made in two
right
as he restarts the next run with 15
minutes to go exactly
and 52 Byron oxidwani
photo chess and the chat also saying
that Liam had 52. oh
that would be a little bit more
comfortable but in this field honestly
anything can happen we saw in the
previous round Andrew Tang all of a
sudden hitting the score to uh continue
in the next round instead of getting
eliminated so anything can happen until
the very last second
yeah 52 is not a very big question I
think it will be enough
I think it will be enough
uh to qualify AA 175 he needs to step it
up right now everybody has at least one
50 point run other than him
let's see if he can um
if you can get this moving here goes
Liam
okay nice
very quick G4 wow
what do you do here Bishop oh Rook takes
G2 Bishop D5 oh cutting off The Rook
good catch I think that's it
yeah
but what are you after king of one
just Bishop C4 Bishop C4 forced the king
to take way too long he's got to make it
he's gotta gamble right you've got to
take a risk at some point no no no no no
it's not just definitely not Bishop D5
he did have the idea but not the right
execution Rook takes G2 is such a sneaky
move and really hard to spot
yeah
okay here he goes again
foreign
squeezy
first one you always go like this very
fast very straightforward rarely
mistakes unless it's a mouse lip yeah or
uh
or something very concrete but generally
they always have this right
I like that sound the computer the
computer fan sound
Okay let's listen in
I'm starting out to win so
thanks for the phone you're so adorable
I just have to maintain it
takes a nice idea
this voice is softer than mine that's so
adorable
as it is
check the meat coming
take setting up the meat they start the
critique
um check Chuck take the Jeep one
chuck chuck mate
check me 40.
oh
stupid
oh you said oh dear
oh I just got really wholesome vibes
from him oh yeah no Liam's great
Queen F3 Bishop H3
lift The Rook to E6 I think you'll check
[Music]
uh Bishop thank you everyone for the
fun
oh
[Music]
we're being told to each other you had a
fun match with the Liam last night yeah
yeah we played two matches in a row the
last few days he's
gave me a run for my money yesterday for
sure
what is this one
I
chuck oh that was wow
can he get 50
uh it's Queen E4 probably
you got 50.
I can't see how much time is remaining
it's clearly not a lie seconds oh that's
it 50. thank you everyone for the
followers
crazy
foreign
[Music]
what is happening
this is addicting I think Liam stream is
going to be the new the new hugaro you
know
yeah this is really fun to watch we also
have something else that's really fun to
watch the person for you is solving from
an iPad and we have live footage of him
doing so look at that
wait this overlay is awesome no it's
amazing
what there's like a TV
this reminds me of like virtual reality
scenes that streamers put up and it's
just insane screens it looks exactly the
same yep
iPad technique indeed and with nine
minutes to go on the ticker
Christopher you currently in third place
but not enough to qualify directly
he needs a nice little 55.
this is so satisfying to watch
it really is
it's Mesmerizing the way that screen is
is tilted
nice nice okay 40.
get out of the checks
we do F4 yep 41.
42 h3h2 quick one to get 43 over a
minute remaining he's got a chance for a
big run here oh never mind was it maybe
bishop E7
oh it might have been to cut off the cut
off the queen yeah yeah
Queen G7 beautiful
but he's dragging to pieces I tend to
click often on my touch screen
yeah I don't understand how he's doing
that so smoothly
yeah because get out of the checks how
do you do that
oh Rook shoe one oh my gosh that was
insane
foreign
I think it's Pawn F4 and Knight C3
puzzle Rush
in the chat uh someone said that it
looks like uh he's playing Fruit Ninja
and honestly I I I I agree I don't think
he's actually playing chess he's just
playing Fruit Ninja I've never played
Fruit Ninja but
you know or any video game or any
computer games that matter
no you haven't oh no
ninja never played Candy Crush
never played Angry Birds or like any
popular game
I'm really disappointing you right now
it's okay you're you know I'm a grandma
you're not missing out on the law it's
it's fine
yeah GMS are not known for their
well-rounded nature you know
Liam got 51.
but right now
right now A A 175 got 52. so you kind of
called it am I a 51 might not make it
Liam stands to be eliminated or now
together with
uh saravan and
slippery Speedster but it looks like
Liam got 52.
oh
it's getting really close out 51 is not
even wow 51 is now also 52. Liam with
52. so he builds up a little cushion but
right now Min might not even qualify on
52 because of his bad tie breaks
unbelievable
let's see unbelievable meanwhile
Christopher you 41 with one minute and
around 15 seconds left
he's got a big shot here time for two
more runs or so less than six minutes
remaining in this penultimate round
we've got one more after this to
finalize the list of players who make it
to tomorrow but a a strike there for
Christopher and another one
oh yeah that's strike was a was a slip
he knew the solution yep and that's the
dangers of solving on an iPad yep
oh
what a tough one 48
still has some time
it is possible
wait you can't even see the whole screen
on the yeah on the iPad it's like
weirdly reflected
oh queen of singing yep
Queen H5 no
no there's nine of six I oh and you
attack the queen what was it I guess it
was just take on H7
probably yeah and bring it over to the
Rook exactly
Frederick svane 56 looks like that's
gonna stand
and it looks like Andrew but uh is 55
should be enough
pretty good news
crazy the men with a 52-point run
Knockouts might not make it through
Jesus The
Best of the Best
hmm
but still competing against Rey and
jimis is just
it's a lost cause
yeah
look how close the scores are there's
not the players are so close together
with their scores there's not one
sticking out by far
I think we should go to Min for the last
four minutes to see if he can make it
out of the bottom three
so if we could pull up Midstream at some
point
because badur with 54 should make it
yeah Christopher at the very least will
make it through to the next round
but Min Lee he needs a 53 Point
performance to get out of that bottom
three as you can see his tie breaks just
aren't good
yeah neither is his body language he
seems a little bit dejected here
can he pull out an Andrew Tang like
miracle
let's find out rotate C3 there you go
this is Checkmate another checkmate
oh he's taking some time here he needs
to speed up
he needs to gamble because he's got time
for one more run after this one and
that's it
so you have strikes no mouse slips he's
got a Gamble and he's got to put
together a huge run okay so far so good
30 minutes he's gonna get 30.
or so in a minute
oh Rook F3 and C4 oh
do you want Queen B6 okay 30.
seven somewhere oh just the first move
nice
E5
six in the pawn runs
Rook got five fantastic run so far from
in this is a chance
Rook takes C6
wow more good stuff take the Knight
take the Rook which one do you take
oh you get the night around and out
mm-hmm
oh 26. oh that was a beautiful one but
still he's in it and you can't lose hope
you can still do it with this score
plenty of time 40 with a minute 15
that's as good as it gets but this is
Queen F2 probably Queen F2 he's
overthinking it
no
you mouth slipped
okay he's gonna get one more chance
he's gonna get one more time yeah
last chance for men
he needs to do it now 53.
or a better tie break on 52 but 53 would
make him in would put in mistake spot
yeah yeah exactly so she is taking a
deep breath preparing himself and it
makes sense he doesn't it doesn't matter
when he starts this last run as long as
he starts it in the next minute 15 so he
needs to steal himself
gather himself
and he needs 53 on demand to stay in the
tournament here we go
here goes men
not yet
yeah he's taking time yeah Gathering his
strength
all right there we go
here we go can he pull out the miracle
run at the end
to avoid elimination 53 is necessary
a little oh this is so stressful
couple close calls there but so far so
good for men taking Rook a seven take
the Rook
mate he needs a couple really quick ones
here
yeah I can't imagine what this is like I
mean
so stressful he knows that he needs to
get 53 now
so far a pretty good run he needs to try
for 30 in a minute
to set yourself up for success
he's going to be a little bit less than
that he might be at 25
. there we go quick one and 25 and
Counting nice
Rook takes D2 first 26 in a minute okay
pretty decent
got a shot 28.
can he make it 29 or do you go now
ship F3 a lot of stuff
Queen takes yeah Queen takes oh there's
a bishop on A7 oh my gosh and that was
blocked by the bits that he was
receiving
and an easy mate there for 32.
uh I think you take the Rook I think
scene two queen takes D2 gotta Rush
Gotta Go Gotta Go Gotta Go
he's six Maybe
I think it is E6 probably
he found it rookie won that took him a
while though
when she took off on a couple quick ones
thanks to it Brooke yeah looks good
38.50 he ate
and he's taking the Rook on the D1 go go
go go go
he's hesitating too much he needs to
speed up he's got 40 and he needs 12
more in a minute and he's got one of
them
and there's the second one an easy mate
where is it there it is and there it is
43 he's moving right along
oh oh my God oh my gosh this is amazing
H4 this one's easy 45.
35 seconds though that's not a lot 46.
you need seven more I don't think he's
gonna get it I don't think he's gonna
get it
oh gosh Bishop Diego
47 okay he needs to gamble 20 seconds
remaining
48 oh my gosh this is gonna be close
Rook takes C5 49 he's gonna get to 50.
Rook takes
it Quincy one oh no he won't make it he
won't make it
he ends with 50 and that's it for minlay
he is eliminated because this score his
final score was not enough
so close that was a valiant effort we
thought he might get it but he was just
a little too slow in those First puzzles
still what a run what a run it was for
minli but he gets eliminated along with
slippery Speedster that's Robin ranjith
and aa175 who's 52 points is not enough
and Fredericks vane and Andrew Tang
early on with beautiful scores 56 and 55
they are through to tomorrow and that
leaves us with one two three four five
players remaining three of whom are
going to be eliminated two of whom are
gonna make it through by the skin of
their teeth in the final round so ladies
and gentlemen don't go anywhere the
finale of day one of the puzzles World
Championship will be coming your way
very very soon we're gonna take a quick
break and we will be back with a final
round in just a couple of short minutes
interested in becoming a chess streamer
like your favorite creators such as
Hikaru Gotham chess and the botan
sisters come on
chess.com is excited to announce the
community streamer program
whether you're just getting started with
streaming or already established and
looking to expand your audience you can
now connect your account to chess.com
and have your stream promoted on the
game's largest platform
simply link your account at chess.com
settings slash connected accounts set
your category to chess on Twitch and
start streaming you'll get an ad free
experience on chess.com you will pop up
on our list of live streamers your
chess.com profile will feature your
Twitch stream
and your stream will be linked to your
games on our play server type command
Community streamer in chat and start
growing your stream today
thank you
[Music]
City Lights
thank you
[Music]
foreign
and then there were five five players
remain unqualified and uneliminated at
the puzzles world championship and that
is why we have one more round to
determine the two lucky players who
squeak through to day two in the three
unlucky players who will be going home
after today and Amaya it's been an epic
day one we've had amazing performances
all around of course Ray Robson didn't
take him very long to qualify but who
are going to be the two final lucky
players to get those final two
qualifying spots yeah Dania welcome back
everyone I am beyond excited for this
final round because as you mentioned
there's only five left we've seen so
many amazing puzzle rushes by those
participants but now it is their final
chance to qualify for tomorrow's final
knockout bracket tomorrow will be
decided who will go home with the title
puzzle world champion 2023 but today we
have this final round another 30 minutes
of three minute puzzle rushes I'm beyond
excited for this Dania me too we will
get started very soon the prizes are
generous we remind you that since there
are five players left the top two
finishers qualify to tomorrow's knockout
Puzzle Battle knockout while the bottom
three are going to be limited to the
minimum prize for tomorrow is a thousand
bucks so Ray Robson Jim is all of those
players have already secured a minimum
prize of twenty five thousand dollar
overall prize fund in Amaya
yeah huge prizes and the players are or
today have also been playing for some
nice prizes a few hundred dollars wear
at stake so
um yeah a lot of prizes till we won
today and tomorrow and we'll see who
goes next who goes through to tomorrow's
final knockout bracket okay so as we get
uh things started here we'll get 30
final minutes of puzzle rushing we have
bad or jababa Christopher you we've got
a couple of very enterprising players
who still are trying to make their way
into tomorrow's
uh into tomorrow's
knocked out section this is
nerve-wracking nmi I really can't
imagine what they feel like these are
the final 30 minutes you don't have any
other opportunities so if you're
Christopher if you're a bad door you
need 55 you need 56 I mean 53 might not
even make it through might not even make
it through right all of those players
all five of them they are equally strong
in this format and it is just about who
has a better run in those 30 minutes
anything can happen and they need to
prove themselves in those 30 minutes so
um the games the puzzles are about to
start the match clock will run very soon
uh but for now the players are
practicing normally I would say I would
take a deep breath and take a pause but
these players are continuing they don't
stop
no they do not you got to keep going and
you mentioned at the very start the role
of fatigue the more you solve the less
consistent you become because the more
tired you get your hands get tired your
brain gets tired but right now these
players actually need their strongest
performances of the day if they want to
secure the top two spots we also have
Liam Putnam uh a very enterprising young
player who's been impressing us with
both his stream and his performances
here he goes oh it's so adorable yeah
it is and the clock should start any
second now
we've got about a minute and a half
before the clock starts
okay
[Music]
let me throw on this one tick I love the
narration too
um the fact that he has time for it we
just make it
Chuck
a meat
Chuck Chuck and me for a typical uh
pattern his score is insane
yeah 47 and unfortunately this will not
count but you know this isn't actually
counting because I'm doing okay there
you go like it too bad I can't do this
one on the clock is ticking
cheek
that wins
not correct okay
um how do we
which way do we go the queen Knight
takes up six and check oh deal oh I'm
just gonna film a few more
and of course
five you gotta go the other way because
here the Fawn runs forward to F5
right or G4 H4 yeah okay thank you yeah
I'm definitely gonna have to do that
um
says
it says that we have um
a few seconds three seconds
three seconds Liam here we go the bell
sounds the clock begins 30 minutes to
stop uh ticking down yep there you go it
started
all right let's go final 30 minutes of
today's puzzle Rush festivities to
determine the final two qualifying spots
will Liam
be among the lucky ones
okay let's roll here we go let's watch
his first run
okay
yep
no that's exactly right
wait he's also
the Hikaru style all right give a check
make a check make a mate or la la
logical
rainbow
rhyming cocoa they're they're the
problem that that moves just check check
and make a check make a mate I make it
four make a check sorry
[Applause]
[Music]
um
I just want to get on the school board
first before I start good call
trying to get a really high school I
could still get like 15. Plus in this
one
money is so aware I really love storage
yes no he's awesome he really deserves
to go through he's Sharp As Nails
[Music]
nope
and this one just come back Bishop Chuck
mate because the pin
um so fast your ticks and then take the
queen
go to the corner he's explaining every
single move it's unbelievable
[Music]
hey I'm down
do I teach this is coming
so how do I deal with this threat I feel
like you I think Rook H3
o no some sort of uh reflection
[Music]
insanely hard problem
so precise what
because night things
yeah because in that position the
Bishops there's a fork in the end
gosh this seems like he's been solving
them correctly for hours and he's only
got 44s it's brutal
yeah um
teeth and you take
wow Knight ba what a move
I haven't
where did the queen that came
okay it's 47 not uh not bad not the
worst
no far from it roundock already has 53.
jeez
so I have
round five I haven't
yeah 51 is a mistake that should be
removed because this was his first run
chocolate right
all right let's watch the next run
wow look at that Mouse speed
I would almost argue this is faster than
Andrew Tang
alien competition no question about it
and he's so fast that at changing the
direction of the piece like he'll start
with the wrong move sometimes and then
he'll immediately change it to the right
move
oh goodness yeah
very resourceful
for q1 May and no mouse slips
I guess I will jinx them very surely
he is in a Zone look at this look at the
speed E5
he jinxed himself
I almost tried to make that but it was
illegal roller coaster
I mean when the system does not allow
you to make the wrong move
yourself a shotgun of six or no yes we
check and Bishop of feet very nice I
love the the conversation he's having
with himself uh it's lovely
Chuck and the meat's coming takes Chuck
ticks I mean to be fair the fact that
you're uh discussing the puzzles even if
it's very briefly it keeps you focused
you're not really getting distracted
easily and you're holding yourself
accountable like you're not allowing
yourself to do anything too sloppy
because you have to announce what it is
that you're doing no no no no it's Queen
h6b foreign
[Music]
he might get 50 this time
there's a minute on the clock I think
King D7 is an important move we hit the
ship
Advance yes
King E6 what a difficult move wow Queen
F1 and H4 it's amazing Queen G2 good job
[Music]
tonight
here there's also
keep looking Oh What a fine
but actually no take on f8 obvious yeah
okay uh
well in okay we're surviving just barely
so
we have to get like a mid 50s 54
something like that and secure
peel this all right here he goes again
thank you everyone for the following
this follower goal today so cute
speed up here it's just this is very
very wholesome
[Music]
cakes Christopher you with 55s he's got
in the top spot right now
cheeks
take two four take the coin
take you this is mate here takes
opposition
um
it's just the automatic sound at this
point the followers sound
exactly like background music now
yeah maybe even have some focus in some
weird way
take this way and then goodness what
wait he's actually hitting the 500
followers there he goes good job guys
I'm way too slow this time
yeah but this is a tough batch it's not
really his fault yeah
[Music]
no Bishop D6 Bishop D6
this time I think that's the most uh
that's the smallest thing I can't
believe how many people are following
thank you so much crazy
he's so composed that his composure is
insane natural board streamer
he's not even getting frustrated at the
fact that he like made a mistake like a
very straightforward one or something
he's just like yeah I think it's best if
I uh do a new run it's crazy
okay I'll stretch everyone thank you
oh
he's doing some stretches I mean this is
honestly full you got the full package
here I
[Music]
like that but maybe I do this is amazing
meat meat
pin here
okay by George Baba is having a huge run
right now he's got 42 with a minute left
and no strikes let's switch to his
stream
oh can he make it 43 now
44.
Queen Ace Rook A6 oh my God
uh uh oh my gosh
C1 and queen C2 Bishop E3 wow
maybe seven and then
exactly no that you're you're that was
correct
yeah it's the first move and then the
next one's like uh I'm not sure anymore
oh I apologize he did have two strikes
so he won't make it to 50. foreign
's a little bit cut off but yeah that
seemed like a good run
he's got so much going on on his screen
that night in the corner I'm like it
[Laughter]
okay
do you check me to check me checkmates
exactly AK4
Channel your inner Liam Putnam
yeah butter seems very focused
no time for conversations
oh Queen G8 that's a tough one Bishop
takes G6 check not an easy move to play
intuitively
Queen F1
King on the Run
nope wrong way wrong way Jose King F6
was the move there
rooked you would
yep
36 one and a half minutes left not bad
but is it enough let's have a strike and
he's got to get the next couple quickly
correct there we go King oh he goes the
right way and promotes
oh we take the mission first you take
the bishop first there he's got 40. but
he's got two strikes again and that's
almost impossible
yeah
Queen H4
yeah you see two checks and it's so hard
to see which one is better
especially when you're putting pressure
on yourself to solve quickly oof and you
got the first one yeah
all right here he goes
mate mate
mate made made made made
all right Queen D7
I have to yep yep
it's like the puzzles just like are
flashing by you know me yep at this you
blink and it's gone
I can't even imagine how they're keeping
up their speed given how long they've
been solving for I mean these last five
players are the Unlucky ones they have
to solve the longest of anybody to give
themselves a chance to qualify
they do get rewarded for staying on for
so long but still the ultimate price
like the final price obviously to
qualify that's what matters
and we did mute his stream because you
know we do have a young it's earlier in
the day so we are expecting younger uh
twitch viewers to to be tuned in
and uh obviously it's it's your right to
handle your stream how you want to but
we want to keep it family friendly
looks like Bud are losing a little bit
of steam but this is a potentially big
run no strikes yet take the bishop first
oh I I jinxed him
that's totally my fault
Queen E3 maybe and then no it's Rook H1
first check yeah the other one
okay so it's again
and we've got a little bit more than
half of the ticker still alive so plenty
of time remaining
but that time evaporates so quickly in
the blink of an eye each run takes three
minutes so not a lot of runs left
quick checkmates here and there
mm-hmm
Checkmate yep
it's a nasty one to face Bishop G7 there
yeah
he's getting a very very tough batch
here for sure race 58 is indeed the best
score of the day not a surprise that the
best score of the day was achieved by
Ray in the second best by ledopolis also
known as jimis
Queen H4 is correct
maybe after this run we could tune into
mitrava because we haven't tuned into
his stream just yet and I would love to
see how he's doing in his runs would be
nice to uh for some variety and quietly
you know he hasn't had any huge scores
over 55 but he's been very consistent
with 52-53 and you know that's a totally
full-fledged strategy there he is as the
match uh tournament clock hits 15
minutes
15 minutes remaining in today's puzzle
Rush festivities now less here goes me
trouble let's watch I love his
headphones
yeah I love the RGB yeah kind of cool
very flashy
and so is this puzzle Rush skills
nice
[Laughter]
oh Queenie Queenie a queen E8 oh no he's
having a complete blind spot right now
it's oh he's getting tired you can just
sense that he's getting tired
must be uh maybe it's later for him as
well looks like it's pretty dark he has
it yeah if he's in India I would imagine
it's probably about midnight
and not everybody's a d-gen
now he has a 51 Point run but that's not
going to be enough oh he's really
tilting
yeah
he has to get out of this because
there's already 13 minutes left
and right now
to get those top two spots Christopher's
already claimed one of them with 55 so
you basically need 53 or 54.
oh no he's so tilted right now
yeah this is the worst I mean it's so
hard to keep up for so long especially
at around this time
by the way Christopher you is building
up another big run
okay we're keeping an eye on him
53 can he get to 55.
oh where does the queen go
Queen
I have no idea Queen where oh queen
queen the queen no
ah
he just emitted a JC right there
and round action with 52 coins roundak
right now in the second spot but 52 is
as unstable as it gets anybody could get
53 in this field
but right now badur is really scuffling
he hasn't managed a 50-point run just
yet
shall we go back to Liam and see if he
can one up his 51 points let's take a
look
all right I know he's your favorite so
yep he's checking the timer he's got to
go Gotta Go Gotta Go he's he's too
focused on on what the timer's showing
you now you got to get as many runs in
as possible
what's he waiting for I'm not sure let's
go Liam
he is currently
sitting in second to last place you've
got to make the top two
so right now oh bad door got 52. oh
and badur jumps from last place to
second place he passes around exoduani
crazy
now you need 53.
all right Liam let's see if he has a
magical run in store in the last 10
minutes
all of those players are capable of
hitting 55. they're all capable of it
without question
shoot this glitch right when I don't
need it
when I need that
wonderful yeah it works perfectly and
you don't
what is that
okay nasty
are you in the room
but how yeah I think it is H4 oh but the
queen E3 is a good point oh yeah so I
guess it is two two yeah that's correct
tough one oh he's he's wasting too much
time
no no no no that's the going the wrong
way too long
you found it in the end
good resilience but not a lot
to catch up now
because I tanked on that one puzzle I
have to take take Bishop he said 27.
C4 Queen E4 Queen E4
centralized the queen take
um
do I want to go this way or does it King
heel
it's a this is impossible oh I have no
idea
okay incredible oh shoot
[Music]
coin thanks yeah okay
good okay take the Rook okay 43 so far
so good
[Music]
nine and a half remaining on the match
clock
but not a lot of time in this run
cage six yeah he's just a little too
slow on that one puzzle he's going so
fast through the 40s
yeah we got seven he's seven wow
oh
I think his time is evaporating though
yep
uh oh my gosh insane
we have a little bit more time eight
minutes 54 seconds
plenty of time right now
if I'm doing chat right now I really
put I just um I
don't focus on the board he's so cute I
mean this honestly is adorable
and and also very impressive obviously
his skills are phenomenal
[Music]
okay this is very good Lightning Fast
lightning fast start
oh look at this he's got a couple easy
ones here so he really should try to get
30.
another easy one
another one
easy clap nastasia's mate Rook be one
mate take the Rook
wow it was a mesmerizing speed right now
30. this is insane one Bishop A6 for 32
no it's been in one
and it's it happens right because you're
you're forcing yourself to play so fast
that you're just like sometimes your
brain just doesn't catch up yeah and
you're you tend to tunnel vision as well
you see some tactic but it doesn't work
yeah that is going to be a hard one to
survive
he got one wrong
okay you know C2 has got to be the move
and Rook D3
wow that was a tough one oh big one
there take the bishop Knight T8 F6
oh 97.
[Music]
no Queen B1 what
insane
laughs
[Music]
two and D4 it's it's C2 and D4 Missy
plays D4 first correct what
because if you had gone to C2 first then
Rook C1 D4 you could take C2 yeah the
magician
crazy stuff
it too seems fair and then what rookie
won for sure Rook G1 Rook takes G1 no no
no no no no that's wrong there we go
very close call
push it baby
yep
and now what we're missing a piece here
Rook A8 and Rook takes C7 it's Rook A8
oh yeah and this glitch that's massive
oh the glitch he's got her own he spent
a couple no he's got to do it again
rookie eight oh that's so unfortunate oh
no
got him Knight H2 Knight H2 doesn't get
flustered
65 mate
good stuff 47.
49.
there is
now you you begin to see how impressive
raise robson's like consistent 56 is
and how insane that is
yeah time for incredible two more runs
here
needs 53.
[Music]
can he get it
his pace is amazing but the problem is
you need to keep it up throughout the
entire run and also be accurate and that
is what is making this so hard
no 50 if you think about it in that way
a 53 is just a ridiculous score
yeah you gotta pace yourself here but so
far so good
oh he doesn't stop
Rook H5 I think no no his mate oh my
gosh Lily I'm avoiding traps here
to get to 32.
here's 33 the lobster picture there's no
check
E6 is correct
okay Bishop F7 keep it simple when the
Knight this should be five fork
Knight F2 with another Fork take with
the queen no don't take Knight takes H3
oh
that was a tough one still a good run
so what am I missing
no Knight G3 Bishop takes F2 Knight G3
there's Bishop takes F2
oh no he's a trust his instinct
that took too long
already
oh what a puzzle
wow
apparently during the break he kept
doing puzzles so his viewers wouldn't
get bored oh that is adorable
this is phenomenal solving by Liam
honestly this is just very impressive
E6 yeah I think that does it
just I mean it's it's much easier to
solve when you're watching and he's
still doing it better than I would
Knight G6
wow
[Music]
oh he still has some time left can he
make it
night somewhere maybe just Rook takes E4
I think if you keep it simple here oh
but wasn't there Rook f8 it wasn't
possible I I don't recall
oh what a puzzle he solved it he's got
50. Bishop F6 no take the bishop
beautiful 51 I don't see how much time
is left he's got 52. can he get to 53
kick again
what a clutch performance with two
minutes left but it's not enough Donya
oh because round neck has 54.
no he's not no
no
raunak has gotten 54.
no this is insane how does 53 not
qualify
you have to be kidding me
he's saying what we're all thinking
literally like everything that's on my
mind he is saying
okay but he has time for basically one
more complete run he's got to give it
his best
it's not going to be easy indeed even if
he doesn't qualify what an insane run by
Liam 53
that is just a score to hang your hat on
for sure oh no he's got to restart he's
got to restart
oh no getting kind of flustered here
yeah this is really tough he still has a
minute left on the match clock
[Music]
okay speed is phenomenal
honestly the people's favorite with one
minute remaining this is the last run
for all of the players Christopher has
made it round act has made it right now
can anybody get 54.
oh
anything can still happen in the final
seconds
we saw that from Andrew Tang Queen A3
good job by Liam averted disaster
oh my goodness look at that Speed Queen
G4
great stuff
oh what a tough puzzle there he got it
instantly yeah there's a mating
mechanism
getting E4 and push
oh gotta stop the king
good job
okay each one yep
checkmate
bowden's mate there with Queen takes C3
I think that you got to give a check on
C5 beautiful wow take G7 first
uh oh Liam this is amazing
time's up but he's still in his run
with no strikes can he make it oh this
is tough I have no idea what this one is
it might be F5
yeah he finds it come on
H4 at the untrap the night take the
Knight you gotta go quick what E5 D4 E5
oh the emotions enough he gets another
one Queen H4
here it is for 46.
take that Knight G4 Knight H7 maybe what
48 an easy one there Knight T3 made in
two oh 49.
Rook D4 Rook D4
ah this is tough he finds it
they're 50 there's 50.
can he get to 54.
oh I don't see it I don't know it Bishop
G5 is right
I this is so difficult
was me yeah
oh wait wait wait wait wait
no time's up that's it time's up and
this was his final chance oh that was so
sad close and heartbreaking
that is heartbreaking but listen he got
53 I mean you literally cannot do any
better than that unless you do Puzzle
Battle
basically all day every day 53 is really
As Good As It Gets there's mitraba he's
on his last run
he's on his last run he needs 53 and
he's actually doing a pretty good job
here 43.
oh there's still a chance
the new score to be reached is 55 now
that is a tough one though
yeah it's Rook B7 no
he's not gonna get it
it's nice that's it no yeah 96 was the
move and the thing with Liam is even if
he had gotten 54 that wouldn't have been
enough because raunak one-upped his own
score and got 55.
crazy is going to try he's on his last
run this is the last run of the day guys
but I don't think he's going to get 55
30 seconds left with 43 I don't think so
and that was also his last strike all
right that's it that's it folks
Christopher you and ronaksudwani 55 is
the qualifying score and the last three
players are eliminated they include Liam
Putnam who honestly did amazing today
as the jababa and mitrabba
all of them scoring over 50.
that was such an excitement to watch
Daniel I mean the final five they all
deserve to be tomorrow in the final
knockout bracket but only two of them
made it and it was so heartbreaking to
see Liam not making it as well as all
the others that didn't make it but we do
have eight players that are moving on to
tomorrow's knockout there you go look at
those scores look at those scores I mean
55 is the minimum qualifying score for
today and it's not a surprise that it
came at the end as fatigue set in still
just amazing Ray Robson solidifies his
reputation as the king of puzzle body he
has the highest score of today but he's
got some competition Jim is with 57 and
Philippians 46. I'm very excited to
watch him tomorrow that's young
International Master Andy Woodward so
we've got the bracket set for tomorrow
it's going to be a pretty standard
bracket as you can see right facing
Brown act we've got some mouth-watering
matchups though how about Woodward
against Christopher you and Amaya this
is going to be super entertaining
absolutely Diane I cannot wait to see
this action on the fall tomorrow those
matches are so exciting and I'm really
excited I'm pumped to see who is going
to advance to the finals and it is
double elimination so you get two
chances
but uh Ray Robson he probably will not
need two chances we're gonna keep an eye
on him as well as all of the other
players tomorrow the winners bracket
comes your way at noon Eastern start
time 9 A.M Pacific same start time as
today and we will be bringing you the
commentary tomorrow as well so something
to look forward to as you kick off your
Friday anime I'll pass it to you one
last time for your final thoughts before
I wrap up
it was a pleasure commentating together
with you Dania it is not easy to comment
on puzzle rush but it was amazing and
tomorrow we will be back with more
excitement and I cannot wait to see who
will become first place in this puzzles
World Championship I hope you all at
home enjoyed this show as much as we did
make sure to do your puzzles as well
since it's free today for everyone as
well as tomorrow and thank you so much
everyone for watching for sure we'd like
to thank Liam Putnam for the raid and
the amazing performance
all right you said it all Anna it was a
pleasure commentating with you as well
we will be back tomorrow at the same
time but for now you were watching the
puzzles World Championship day one we'll
have day two for you tomorrow on Friday
this was women's International Master on
Maya Kazarian and Grandmaster Daniel
nardiski bringing you coverage of the
puzzles World Championship we'll see you
tomorrow bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
thank you